Hey, everybody.
Hey.
Oh, my goodness.
Are we in a good mood today?
We are.
I mean...
You were shut out of a cannon.
I was shot out of a cannon.
嘿，大家好。嘿。天哪。我们今天心情不错吧？是啊。我是说……你就像从大炮里发射出来一样。我确实是从大炮里发射出来的。
I'm all fired up.
We get to do some potting today.
Yeah.
And I'm so excited you two are here for this.
You're going to have such a hoot.
What we do is that little foam thing in front of your mouth, you just speak into that.
We're going to have somebody of interest coming on soon.
You're going to be able to be a hoot.
我浑身充满了干劲。我们今天可以做些播客了。是的。我很高兴你们俩能来参加。你们会玩得很开心的。我们要做的就是对着你嘴前面那个小泡沫球说话。很快就会有位重量级嘉宾要来了。你们会玩得很开心的。
able to ask any questions
that you might have.
And they should respond in a somewhat
informative way. Nobody's left. Nobody's left.
Nobody's going to listen now.
You think they've turned the dial?
Well, then let's hurry up and get the guest out here.
Come on. Welcome to Smartless.
可以问任何你想问的问题。他们应该会以一种比较有信息量的方式回答。没人离开。没人离开。现在没人会听了。你觉得他们换台了吗？好吧，那我们赶紧把嘉宾请出来吧。来吧。欢迎来到Smartless。
What is that from?
Hi.
That's like a...
I'll do smart list.
Oh, my.
Jesus.
Isn't that a...
那是哪里的台词？嗨。嗨。那就像是……我会做Smart list。天哪。上帝啊。那不是……
Isn't that...
Don't they use that in...
Sports things?
Yeah.
Hey, Sean.
Are you doing an ad for All-American guy?
You just took a big gulp of milk, and now you took a bite of an apple.
那不是……他们不是在……体育节目里用那个吗？是啊。嘿，肖恩。是啊。你在给“全美男人”做广告吗？你刚大口喝了牛奶，现在又咬了一口苹果。
Yeah, I just got back.
What happened?
You ran out of Pop-Tarts?
Oh, my God.
Dude, hit the horn again.
There you go.
Hey, did Archie give you that app or something?
Is that next to the fart one?
是啊，我刚回来。怎么了？你的Pop-Tarts吃完了？天哪。伙计，再按一下喇叭。这就对了。嘿，是阿奇给你那个应用程序了吗？那是在放屁那个旁边吗？
No, man.
I've had it for a long time, embarrassing.
enough. Did I tell you, somebody
gave me a box of pop tarts outside the
stage door? Did they
really? Yeah. It was the greatest
gift. What a crowd.
There was a bow around it.
不，伙计。我用很久了，真尴尬。够了。我跟你说过吗，有人在舞台门外给了我一盒Pop-Tarts？真的吗？是啊。那是最好的礼物。多好的观众啊。上面还系着蝴蝶结。
And I was like, that was the nicest gift ever.
Did security tackle them?
No. Remember when we went on tour
and that somebody handed me a sandwich
and I ate it? And Jason
was like, I remember that we got in the car. You're like,
Why would you ever eat a sandwich from somebody off the street?
I'm like, because I was hungry.
我当时想，那是有史以来最好的礼物。保安没把他们扑倒吗？没有。还记得我们巡演时，有人递给我一个三明治，我就把它吃了？杰森当时说，我记得我们上了车。你说，你为什么会吃路人给的三明治？我说，因为我饿了。
You're trying to get me to remember the time that you ate a sandwich?
No.
No?
I just kind of heighten it.
If it's not, if it's dragged across the finish line.
He needs a little punch.
No, I know.
你是想让我记起你吃三明治的那次吗？不。不是吗？不。我只是稍微夸张了一下。如果不是这样，如果它是被拖过终点线的。他需要一点刺激。不，我知道。
By the way, it should be noted.
I text it, J.B.
I'm going to embarrass him.
The boys and I, Artape and I watched that first episode of DTS, St. Louis.
He's so good.
Wait.
Listen,
Jason, you're so good at playing a simp.
顺便说一下，应该提一下。我给J.B.发了短信。我要让他尴尬一下。我和男孩们，阿特佩和我看了DTS的第一集，圣路易斯。他演得太好了。等等。听着，杰森，你演那种卑微的人真是太棒了。
Go ahead, Sean.
I mean, I just, I almost, Jay,
it's like one of those incredible, powerful performances
that I felt like when I saw Willie do his movie too
where I'm looking at you right now,
I've known you for 75,000 years,
and I don't know who you are.
Like, it was so unbelievably a different person
继续，肖恩。我是说，我差点，杰，这就像那种令人难以置信的、强有力的表演，就像我看到威利演他的电影时一样，我现在看着你，我认识你75000年了，但我不知道你是谁。就像，这简直是一个不可思议的、完全不同的人。
that I did not believe I was watching you.
Johnny finished it last night.
I finished the whole series.
Yeah, last night.
How do you have all?
I gave them mine.
We finished the first episode,
and I turned to the boys,
以至于我不相信我是在看你。约翰尼昨晚看完了。我把整个系列都看完了。是啊，昨晚。你怎么会有那么多时间？我把我的给了他们。我们看完了第一集，我转向男孩们，
and I literally looked at my go,
how many episodes away are we from Jason getting pegged?
Jay, I mean, that's pretty close.
I could go on and on.
I know.
It's so good.
I was in tears at the end because I was so proud of my friend Jason.
It's really good.
我真的看着他们说，离杰森被“钉”还有几集？杰，我是说，那很接近了。我可以一直说下去。我知道。太棒了。最后我热泪盈眶，因为我为我的朋友杰森感到骄傲。真的很好。
Everybody's great.
Linda Cardellini is amazing.
David Harbor really great.
David Harbor is great.
I'm not comparing anybody, but Jason, you are so good in this part, honestly.
I really appreciate you.
And it's so, I mean, were you.
And it's not surprising.
每个人都很棒。琳达·卡德里尼太棒了。大卫·哈伯真的很好。大卫·哈伯很棒。我不是在比较任何人，但杰森，说实话，你在这个角色里演得太好了。我真的很欣赏你。而且，我是说，你当时……这并不令人惊讶。
It should be noted, too, because, you know, when people go, you were really good.
Always hurts.
But I texted Jason yesterday last night about, like, what a huge.
swing it was to
to do this i mean will
wait until you see
i don't say it in another word i don't know
a new one came out last night and i couldn't watch last night
也应该提一下，因为，你知道，当人们说，你演得真好。总是让人受伤。但我昨晚给杰森发了短信，关于，这是一个多么巨大的转变。我是说，等着看吧，我不用别的词了，我不知道昨晚出了新的一集，我昨晚没能看。
so right i mean it just this guy
Steve conrad this writer-director
we'll leave the subject sorry listener
but this guy Steve connor this writer-director
he's just so
creative and like daring and
yeah but like without being obnoxiously like
oh look how
所以，我是说，这个家伙史蒂夫·康拉德，这个编剧兼导演，我们就不提这个话题了，抱歉听众们，但这个家伙史蒂夫·康拉德，这个编剧兼导演，他太有创造力了，而且很大胆，是的，但又不会让人觉得讨厌，比如“看我多前卫”。
alvanguard and and you know
it's just
Like, it's so...
It serves the characters
It's so relatable
that it makes it absolutely
almost impossible to watch
because it's so cringy and real and awkward.
你知道，这只是……它服务于角色，它太容易引起共鸣了，以至于让人几乎无法观看，因为它太尴尬、太真实、太别扭了。
And so much so, I woke up today
I started doing just regular whatever tasks
thinking about DTF St. Louis
and these characters and I'm like...
Were you sitting on Scotty's face?
Those are his regular tasks.
Way to you...
Check.
以至于我今天醒来，开始做一些日常琐事，脑子里还在想《DTF圣路易斯》和这些角色，我在想……你当时坐在斯科蒂的脸上吗？那是他的日常琐事。你……检查一下。
Wait a minute.
The viewers will understand what we're talking about.
Yeah, that's a little precursor what happens.
But anyways, incredible.
You're very nice.
Thank you, men.
Willie, it's nice to have you back in the States.
You made it.
等一下。观众会明白我们在说什么。是的，那是对接下来发生的事情的一点预告。但无论如何，太不可思议了。你太好了。谢谢，伙计们。威利，很高兴你回到美国。你成功了。
Was there any issues at the border, or was it pretty smooth?
Still good.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I'm in good standing.
边境有什么问题吗，还是挺顺利的？还是很好。还是很好。还是很好。是啊。好吧。是的，所以我现在的状态很好。
Your bronze are still, you haven't run out of that.
No, no.
It's a little streaky.
Fresh toothed.
I can't get behind.
I can't see.
And my feet, obviously, my feet are always a mess when I get sprayed as much.
I used to go to that thing all the time.
你的古铜色还在，你还没用完那个。不，不。有点条纹。刚刷过牙。我跟不上。我看不到。而且我的脚，显然，我喷得那么多，我的脚总是很乱。我以前经常去那个地方。
Did you used to go to those things?
Remember that?
In the boxes?
I've never done it.
No, I've literally never done it.
Do you remember the episode of Rested Development when David Cross had to blow himself or blew it?
He says, I just blew myself.
He had to put on his own blue man makeup.
你以前去过那些地方吗？还记得《发展受阻》里大卫·克罗斯不得不把自己涂蓝的那一集吗？他说，我刚把自己涂蓝了。他不得不自己涂上蓝色人的化妆品。
Yes.
I just read this morning, David's got a brand new comedy special.
His ninth one is self-releasing on his website and on YouTube.
I forget the date, but it's probably on now.
Love David Cross. Go see it.
Oh, that's right.
Click it.
Click it and forget it.
是的。我今天早上刚读到，大卫有一个全新的喜剧特辑。他的第九个特辑正在他的网站和YouTube上自行发布。我忘了日期，但可能现在已经上线了。喜欢大卫·克罗斯。去看看吧。哦，对了。点击它。点击它，然后忘了它。
I love D.C.
Wait, one time really quick.
I went into this.
DC, remember he used to start?
Just in the, especially first year, we'd do something, and David go like, that's so late.
Like, we discussed, Jason and I would describe something we'd do to go, that's pretty lame.
And we'd go, oh, sorry, street cred.
We started calling him street cred, which he actually ended up liking.
我爱D.C.。等等，很快说一下。我进入了这个。DC，记得他以前开始的时候吗？就在，特别是第一年，我们会做些什么，大卫会说，那太逊了。就像，我们讨论过，杰森和我描述我们会做的事情，他会说，那太逊了。然后我们会说，哦，抱歉，街头信誉。我们开始叫他“街头信誉”，他最后竟然喜欢上了这个称呼。
It made him laugh.
Hey, street head coming up.
Yeah.
Anyway.
God, I love him.
Shall we?
Yeah, I thought you were going to say something, Shawnee.
No, that subject went too far away.
这让他笑了。嘿，街头信誉来了。是啊。总之。天哪，我爱他。我们要开始了吗？是啊，我以为你要说什么呢，肖尼。不，那个话题扯得太远了。
It's about this tanning thing.
Bring it back.
Because I used to, I was so white when I would have to have an event to go to or something,
my makeup lady from Will & Grace, she would come over on cake on tanning stuff on my face.
Was it Patty?
Yeah, Patty Bunch, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, she's the best.
是关于这个美黑的事情。把它拉回来。因为我以前，我太白了，当我有活动要参加或者什么的时候，我《威尔和格蕾丝》的化妆师，她会过来在我的脸上涂上美黑的东西。是帕蒂吗？是啊，帕蒂·邦奇，是啊。是啊。她是最好的。
And she forgot to do my hands.
Oh, boy.
And I won a SAG Award.
And so, you know, you do the line.
the photos.
I'm holding up the sagg awards
and my hands are as white
as snow and my face
结果她忘了涂我的手。哦，天哪。我赢了一个演员工会奖。所以，你知道，你走红毯，拍照。我举起演员工会奖，我的手白得像雪，而我的脸
is as orange as the sun.
That's up there with
sometimes in a particularly
unemployed summer I will play a bunch of golf
and the tan difference
I'll see it now.
Between a glove hand
and the non-glove hand
却像太阳一样橙。这和有时候在特别失业的夏天我打很多高尔夫球一样，我现在能看到那种美黑差异。戴手套的手和没戴手套的手之间
is very ugly.
All right, great.
Super hashtag-relations.
Yeah, first world problem was extreme. We just lost 50,000 listeners.
Today, we have one of my favorite actors. She always has been. I've had the great fortune
of working with her a couple of times, and it is as good in person as it is on film. She is not only
an actor, but also a producer and a writer, but not just any writer. This is a playwright.
And recently a columnist, which we will talk about. It's very exciting. After more than 25 years of doing
非常丑。好吧，太棒了。超级标签关系。是的，第一世界的问题太极端了。我们刚刚失去了5万名听众。今天，我们请到了我最喜欢的演员之一。她一直都是。我有幸和她合作过几次，她本人和在银幕上一样好。她不仅是一位演员，还是一位制片人和编剧，但不仅仅是普通的编剧。这是一位剧作家。最近还是一位专栏作家，我们稍后会谈到。这非常令人兴奋。在做了25年多的
great work, it's even greater right now.
She's got a new season of her hit show
on Apple starting this spring. She's got a
brand new film being released, has a
very fancy publication of
her essay dropping, and
has successfully gotten
through yet another year of marriage
伟大的工作之后，现在更棒了。她主演的热门剧集的新一季将于今年春天在苹果公司开播。她有一部全新的电影即将上映，有一本非常高级的散文集即将推出，并且成功地又度过了一年婚姻生活，
to a real ding-dong.
She's a unicorn, folks, and
here she is. Please welcome my long-time, nearest and
dearest friend, Ms. Amanda Pete.
Get out here.
Boy, do we have
stuff to talk about?
Hi, Shawnee.
嫁给了一个真正的笨蛋。她是独角兽，伙计们，她就在这里。请欢迎我认识已久、最亲近的朋友，阿曼达·皮特女士。出来吧。天哪，我们有很多事情要聊吗？嗨，肖尼。
Hi, honey, how are you?
I'm okay.
Oh, my gosh.
Hi, Amanda.
You guys, I did almost do like 25 spit dates.
And I wasn't sure if I was supposed to be.
She is prone to a spit tape.
Look at you with a microphone.
嗨，亲爱的，你好吗？我还好。天哪。嗨，阿曼达。你们，我差点就做了25次口水带。我不确定我是否应该……她很容易流口水。看看你拿着麦克风的样子。
Look at you.
Oh, should I put that down?
No, no, no.
Sean has his?
Oh, you guys all have yours.
We're not doing video.
This isn't video?
That's the one we sent you, isn't it?
看看你。哦，我应该把它放下吗？不，不，不。肖恩有他的？哦，你们都有自己的。我们不做视频。这不是视频吗？那是我们发给你的那个，不是吗？
I've just never seen you in this environment.
So it's all new to me.
It's so great to see you.
I'm so excited.
She said me a text.
She said, can I look like a slob?
I go, yeah, I'm on PJs.
I'm always in my PJs.
我只是从来没见过你在这种环境下。所以这一切对我来说都是新的。见到你真好。我太兴奋了。她给我发了条短信。她说，我可以看起来像个邋遢鬼吗？我说，可以，我穿着睡衣。我总是穿着睡衣。
You don't think you're being recorded is your voice.
He only travels into PJs.
Wow, you are really tan, Will.
I know, I know.
I get that a lot.
As you know.
Smoking and sun.
Not good.
你以为你没被录音，那是你的声音。他只穿着睡衣旅行。哇，你真的很黑，威尔。我知道，我知道。我经常听到这个。如你所知。吸烟和晒太阳。不好。
I know.
Yeah.
Okay.
Wait, wait.
Is it still happening, Will?
We're still chipping?
It's still really annoying that you're so.
so good with addictions now, I guess.
我知道。是啊。好吧。等等，等等。还在发生吗，威尔？我们还在“削减”吗？你现在对成瘾这么擅长，真是太烦人了，我想。
You've got it all handled.
You can just chip away at the cigarettes and it doesn't take over?
Yeah, I mean, I'm pretty good.
I go through phases.
I can't do a little of anything.
I know.
Me neither.
I generally can't either.
你都搞定了。你可以只是慢慢戒掉香烟，它不会占据主导地位？是啊，我是说，我挺好的。我经历过不同的阶段。我什么都不能只做一点点。我知道。我也一样。我通常也不能。
Amanda, how are you with sugar?
I'm really bad with sugar.
I mean, it's not great.
Yeah, what's the one thing?
I need it out.
If you could go to an addict's
what circle meeting whatever it's called what would it what would it what would it be for Amanda oh
what's what's the thing you want to kick I can't say it I think oh you can't really I'm just
阿曼达，你对糖怎么样？我对糖真的很糟糕。我是说，这不太好。是啊，那是什么东西？我需要把它戒掉。如果你能去一个成瘾者的圆桌会议，不管它叫什么，那会是什么？那会是什么？那会是什么？对阿曼达来说，哦，你想戒掉什么？我不能说，我想，哦，你不能，我只是
kidding I'm just kidding we talk about porn here all the time that is something I don't have a problem
yeah no what is it I'm addicted to exercise really no for real kidding oh fucking are you
kidding right right do you know me at all Sean it would be sugar for you oh my
my God, I can't, I can't not go a day without eating tons of sugar.
Have you tried to just get it out of the house?
Like, have you tried the thing where it's like proximity?
Well, and then like, I eat an apple.
Like, okay, well, that has sugar, but the good kind.
开玩笑的，我只是开玩笑的，我们在这里一直谈论色情，那是我没有问题的东西，是啊，不，那是什么？我沉迷于锻炼，真的吗？不，说真的，开玩笑的，哦，该死，你在开玩笑吗？你了解我吗，肖恩？对你来说应该是糖，哦，天哪，我不能，我不能一天不吃大量的糖。你试过把它从家里拿走吗？比如，你试过那种关于距离的方法吗？好吧，然后，我吃了一个苹果。比如，好吧，那有糖，但那是好的那种。
But then I'll have a snickers right after this.
Just a full-grown snickers.
I haven't had a snickers since Halloween when I was 14.
But you know what?
I texted these guys the other night.
I came home after doing two shows.
And I had a plate of spaghetti and a donut.
on the same plate.
但之后我会吃一个士力架。就是一个完整的士力架。我从14岁万圣节之后就没吃过士力架了。但你知道吗？前几天晚上我给这些人发了短信。我做了两场演出后回到家。我吃了一盘意大利面和一个甜甜圈。在同一个盘子里。
On the same plate.
Don't you think you're burning enough adrenaline?
That's what I'm saying.
Two shows.
Like it just probably just...
It's a one-man show, too.
That's what I'm saying.
But he sent the photo of the pasta of the spaghetti bolognese
在同一个盘子里。你不觉得你消耗了足够的肾上腺素吗？我就是这么说的。两场演出。就像它可能只是……这也是一个人的表演。我就是这么说的。但他发了那张意大利肉酱面的照片，
and then a chocolate donut with a bite out of it.
So then I FaceTimed him just because I wanted kind of verification
because I thought that he'd set it for the photo for effect.
And sure enough, donut is on the plate.
He's eating them both simultaneously.
Yeah.
I really was.
然后是一个被咬了一口的巧克力甜甜圈。所以我给他在FaceTime上打了电话，因为我想要验证一下，因为我以为他是为了拍照效果才摆在那里的。果然，甜甜圈就在盘子里。他同时在吃它们。是啊。我真的是。我真的是。
And a glass of milk.
I often think how when, you know, I have an 11-year-old,
I often think of how one of the great, great pleasures of being an adult,
a grown-up, is that you can eat your dessert before your meal.
Sure.
Yeah.
There's no rules.
Well, actually, I said, if you remember, I said to you,
还有一杯牛奶。我经常想，你知道，我有一个11岁的孩子，我经常想，作为一个成年人，一个大人的伟大乐趣之一就是你可以在饭前吃甜点。当然。是啊。没有规则。好吧，其实，我说过，如果你记得的话，我对你说过，
were you at an 11-year-old's birthday party?
Yeah.
And I said I stopped by on the way home from one.
Amanda Pete.
Southie.
Yes.
Oh, my God.
你是在参加一个11岁孩子的生日派对吗？是啊。我说我从那里回家的路上顺便去了一下。是啊。阿曼达·皮特。南波士顿人。是的。天哪。
Amanda, you worked with Amanda.
Amanda and I worked together first.
Almost 30 years ago,
we did a film called, I know, sorry.
Sorry to say that number right now.
Jesus.
I don't feel good about it either.
Do you guys both still have your Boston?
阿曼达，你和阿曼达合作过。阿曼达和我第一次合作。将近30年前，我们拍了一部电影叫，我知道，抱歉。抱歉现在说出那个数字。天哪。我对此感觉也不好。你们俩还有你们的波士顿
Sad cards?
Bassin accents.
They almost took our sad cards away.
They came on set.
What did you work on together?
Southie.
It was called Southie.
It was a film about South Boston.
工会卡吗？波士顿口音。他们差点把我们的工会卡拿走。他们来到片场。你们一起合作了什么？南波士顿。它叫《南波士顿》。那是一部关于南波士顿的电影。
Oh, I didn't know that.
How are you? Good to see you? Good, good for you, Amanda.
You're doing good, huh?
Wait, Amanda, did you do the accent, too?
Do you still have it? I think I might have.
Do it just a little bit.
I can't even fucking remember.
Honestly, I can't even fucking remember because I was in fucking dead.
哦，我不知道。你好吗？见到你很高兴？很好，很好，阿曼达。你做得很好，嗯？等等，阿曼达，你也用了那个口音吗？你还有吗？我想我可能有。稍微做一点。我他妈的甚至不记得了。说实话，我他妈的甚至不记得了，因为我当时在……
They're going to kick me out of the condo.
They're going to kick me out of the condo soon.
That was terrible. Wow.
No, that was good.
Condo is good, though. Condo.
Still rolling.
Wow.
他们很快就会把我踢出公寓的。他们很快就会把我踢出公寓的。那太糟糕了。哇。不，那很好。不过公寓很好。公寓。还在继续。还在继续。哇。
Real.
Root.
Rude.
Wait, was Donnie Wahlberg the star of that film?
So Donnie Wahlberg was a star.
Donnie Wahlberg, Rose McGowan, you, me,
and directed by John Shea.
Anne Mira.
真的。根。粗鲁。等等，唐尼·沃尔伯格是那部电影的主演吗？所以唐尼·沃尔伯格是主演。唐尼·沃尔伯格，罗斯·麦高恩，你，我，由约翰·谢执导。安·米拉。
Who, by the way, Sean, I was saying,
I was about to do a play after Southie,
and I was telling her about how I have terrible stage fright,
and I was trying to just chat with her about it,
and she had, you know, she was a chain smoker,
and she just said,
As soon as you want to be good, you're dead.
安·米拉。顺便说一下，肖恩，我当时说，我正要拍一部戏，在《南波士顿》之后，我告诉她我有严重的舞台恐惧症，我只是想和她聊聊，她有，你知道，她是个老烟枪，她只是说，一旦你想表现得好，你就死定了。
Wow.
Wow, that's a good quote.
Isn't that deep?
Yeah, she was cool.
She was no nonsense.
She was cool.
That's kind of cool.
As soon as you want to be good.
哇。哇，那是一句好名言。那不是很深刻吗？是啊，她很酷。她很务实。她很酷。那挺酷的。一旦你想表现得好。
Yeah.
Wait, wait, tell me about the stage fright.
I guess I have that.
I guess we all have that a bit.
Yeah, I figure out how to not flip out at an early stage.
Just drink.
Right before you get on.
Is it, well, yeah.
是啊。等等，等等，告诉我关于舞台恐惧症的事。我想我有那个。我想我们都有点那个。是啊，我弄清楚了如何在早期阶段不崩溃。只是喝酒。就在你上台之前。是吗，好吧，是啊。
You know what I do?
My little sort of trick I've always done for a long time,
especially when you're going to do something kind of live or whatever,
and you're like, I got to get out there, and I just go,
I am where I am, and literally use it, this is energy, okay.
And I just, so don't try to get over it,
do it.
That's incredibly annoying.
你知道我做什么吗？我一直以来用的小技巧，特别是当你要做一些现场表演或者什么的时候，你觉得，我得出去，我就说，我就是我，真的利用它，这是能量，好吧。我就，所以不要试图克服它，去做它。那太烦人了。
Just flip it, just flip it.
Flip it and forget it.
Yeah, I don't have those kinds of nerves, dude.
Honestly, that's a good impression of me.
Now, has it always been like that?
Here we go.
Let's go back to the beginning, Amanda.
Do you have to?
把它翻转过来，把它翻转过来。翻转它，忘了它。是啊，我没有那种神经，伙计。说实话，那是对我的一个很好的模仿。现在，一直都是这样吗？我们开始吧。让我们回到开始，阿曼达。你一定要吗？
A kid.
Yes.
When you were a kid, was it always going to be this?
Like, did you have a plan for this?
Or did you just kind of wing it and, like, the entertainment world kind of came your way?
Or was it like, no, let's set the oars in this direction and start rowing?
I think both parents.
That's good.
一个孩子。是的。当你还是个孩子的时候，一直都是这样吗？比如，你对这个有计划吗？还是你只是随遇而安，娱乐界就找上门来了？还是说，不，让我们把桨朝这个方向划，开始划船？我想父母双方都是。那很好。
That's enough.
Thank you.
And we'll go to our first break.
No, both parents are off crowd.
Both parents were as far from the entertainment business as you could possibly be.
What kind of?
Corporate lawyer.
Yale undergrad, Harvard Law School.
够了。谢谢。我们要进入第一次休息。不，父母双方都是……观众。父母双方都离娱乐业尽可能远。什么样的？公司律师。耶鲁大学本科，哈佛法学院。
My mom was a social worker, psychotherapist.
Wow.
And I feel like they saw acting.
in the beginning, similarly to just,
oh, so you want to start modeling.
You want to join the circus.
You want to be a hooker.
Right.
我妈妈是社会工作者，心理治疗师。哇。我觉得他们一开始看待演戏，就像，哦，所以你想开始做模特。你想加入马戏团。你想做妓女。对。
Yeah.
Wow.
Sex worker.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sex worker.
Did you work to sort of convince him
that that wasn't the way you were seeing it
and what your intentions were?
是啊。哇。性工作者。性工作者。抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，性工作者。你有没有努力去说服他们，那不是你所看到的方式，你的意图是什么？
Or did you just kind of like hide your pursuit?
Yes, I think I was constantly trying to make it appear
less frivolous.
But interestingly,
apropos of what we were just saying,
I think because I had terrible stage fright,
it was much easier for me to book things like
a chapstick commercial or days of our lives.
还是你只是隐藏了你的追求？是的，我想我一直在努力让它看起来不那么轻浮。但有趣的是，顺便说一下我们刚才说的，我想因为我有严重的舞台恐惧症，我更容易预订像唇膏广告或《我们的日子》这样的东西。
Like as soon as I was lucky enough
to get an audition for something like a Clifford Odette's play
or something like that, I was like this.
Just shaking.
And I couldn't do what I was doing in class
you know in real life so so literally stage was was like that that was your kryptonite but being in front
of camera was was less no sorry i didn't explain that right so anything highbrow i was like terrified
oh got so and then anything that was like considered more lowbrow right you kill i could
就像一旦我有幸得到像克利福德·奥德茨的戏剧之类的试镜机会，我就像这样。一直在发抖。我无法在现实生活中做我在课堂上做的事情，所以舞台就像那样，那是你的致命弱点，但在镜头前却没那么……抱歉，我没解释清楚。所以任何高雅的东西，我都吓坏了，哦，所以任何被认为更低俗的东西，我就能
kill it and so then i was undoing what i wanted to portray to my parents
Yeah.
Because I'd be like, well, I'm on a Skittles commercial and they'd be like, I arrest my case.
Right, right, right.
Well, how about that?
That's actually, that's a good strategy to overcome, you know, like don't overvalue
something.
Maybe like find something about whatever you're going to be doing that's giving you
搞定它，然后我就在撤销我想向父母展示的东西。是啊。因为我会说，好吧，我在拍彩虹糖广告，他们会说，我结案了。对，对，对。好吧，那怎么样？这实际上是一个很好的策略，可以克服，你知道，比如不要过度重视某件事。也许找到关于你要做的事情的一些东西，给你
the nerves that sort of undercuts it.
Well, yeah, I mean, not to get too, like, deep about it, but both my kids were, you know,
given offers to go.
go play and then you know you have three oh sorry the two that are home and play soccer yeah at different
times in their soccer careers were offered to play in a higher soccer team and we're like no oh why why
because they were too nervous oh really so it's catching so i gave them my fucking anxiety
anxiety does ding dong david come along with some really helpful fathering advice to these to these young
nervous you know anxiety riddled kids yes i feel like you don't you know you're
神经，这削弱了它。好吧，是啊，我是说，不要太深入地谈论它，但我两个孩子，你知道，都收到了去踢球的邀请，然后你知道你有三个，哦，抱歉，两个在家的，踢足球，是啊，在他们足球生涯的不同时期，被邀请去踢更高级的足球队，我们说不，哦，为什么，为什么？因为他们太紧张了，哦，真的吗？所以它会传染，所以我给了他们我该死的焦虑，焦虑，笨蛋大卫会带着一些非常有用的父亲建议给这些年轻的、紧张的、焦虑缠身的孩子吗？是的，我觉得你不会，你知道，你
doesn't help. No. It's a good balance. We love David. We do love David. Just because he's not in front
of the camera for my sister, Tracy, David created Game of Thrones, your husband. Yeah.
Are your sisters with, sorry, I don't understand the conceit.
My sister. Every once in a while, we have to remind the audience. Good, thank you, Will.
It's helpful. But wait, Amanda, did you, when you were growing up, oh, go ahead.
No, you go. No, Willie, go. No, no, go. You guys are so polite to each other.
Wait, Amanda, when you grew up with a mom in that field, did she kind of try to psychoanalyze you all the time?
Like, did you have somebody to talk to?
没有帮助。不。这是一个很好的平衡。我们爱大卫。我们确实爱大卫。只是因为他不在镜头前，为了我的妹妹特蕾西，大卫创作了《权力的游戏》，你的丈夫。是啊。你的姐妹们，抱歉，我不明白这个概念。我的妹妹。每隔一段时间，我们就得提醒观众。好，谢谢，威尔。这很有帮助。但等等，阿曼达，你，当你长大的时候，哦，继续。不，你来。不，威利，去。不，不，去。你们对彼此太客气了。等等，阿曼达，当你和一个在那个领域的妈妈一起长大时，她有没有一直试图对你进行心理分析？比如，你有人可以倾诉吗？
Was it therapy constantly in the house?
You know what I mean?
Okay.
To be honest, I was, yeah, I was very, very close with her and very, very similar.
And was sent to the therapist right when I came out of her vagina.
Oh, wow.
Wow.
家里一直有治疗吗？你知道我的意思吗？好吧。说实话，我，是啊，我和她非常非常亲近，而且非常非常相似。我一从她阴道里出来就被送去治疗师那里了。哦，哇。哇。哇。
I was like, talk therapy.
Let's go.
You came out with the car keys.
You're like ready to go.
Did you ever feel like you were getting a free analysis from her?
Or was it like, I can't really share with her my feelings because she's just going to psychoanalyze me?
I think that she...
Like was it a plus or a minus?
我当时想，谈话疗法。我们走吧。你带着车钥匙出来了。你就像准备好出发了一样。你有没有觉得你在从她那里得到免费的分析？还是说，我不能真的和她分享我的感受，因为她只会对我进行心理分析？我想她……比如这是一个加分项还是减分项？
Okay.
My sister would disagree.
For me, it was a plus.
I didn't feel like she was looking at me as like a test dummy.
for her psychological theories.
And she was even in psychoanalytic training in the 90s
when I was in college.
And I thought it was really intellectually interesting
好吧。我妹妹会不同意。对我来说，这是一个加分项。我不觉得她把我当作她心理理论的测试假人。而且她在90年代我上大学时甚至还在接受精神分析培训。我觉得她谈论的事情在智力上非常有趣，而且真的真的很有帮助。而且我想因为她觉得她妈妈是一个临床自恋者，她一心想成为一个好的倾听者，并把我和我妹妹看作我们自己。我就是这么感觉的。我想我妹妹觉得有点像有一种心理学行话的正统观念。
what she was talking about and really, really helpful.
And I think because she felt like her mom was a clinical narcissist,
she was hell-bent on being a good listener
and seeing my sister and me for who we were.
That's how I feel.
I think my sister felt a little bit more
like there was this like
psychobabble orthodoxy.
那是年长的兄弟姐妹。那是年长的兄弟姐妹。哦，是啊，我姐姐。你有没有想过，你有没有通过那个过程思考过？你有没有想过，哦，也许这是一个我想进入的领域？你有没有考虑过自己做那个？
That's older sibling.
Oh, yeah, my older sister.
Did you think about, did you think about
through that process?
Did you think, oh, maybe this is an area
that I want to go into?
Did you consider doing that yourself?
好吧，我一直认为演戏有点像那个领域。抱歉，那个问题是问阿曼达的。抱歉。不，肖恩，继续。我，是啊。不，不，不。是啊。是啊，我是说，我想，
Well, I always think acting is a little bit of that area.
Sorry, that question was for Amanda.
Sorry.
No, Sean, go.
I, yeah.
No, no, no.
Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, I think,
当我回顾过去，我当时在，这非常不寻常，我13岁时就在接受精神分析。所以我一周四天去看心理医生。哇。谈谈，你知道，第一世界的问题。而且我认为精神分析的想法是，有一些煽动性的事件让你走上了一条道路，一条轨迹。
when I look back, I was in, this is very unusual,
I was in psychoanalysis at age 13.
So I went to the shrink four days a week.
Wow.
Talk about, you know, first world problems.
And I think the idea of psychoanalysis
that there are these inciting incidents
that set you on a path on a trajectory.
那是讲故事。你基本上是在创造一个叙事。我是说，老派的心理医生，他们不是在创造它。但我认为它在各方面都非常类似于讲故事。然后我们创造，然后那个，创造那个叙事，那些神经通路变得越来越深，越来越深，那些凹槽。如果你是，危险在于如果你不这样做，
And that's storytelling.
You're basically creating a narrative.
I mean, old school shrinks,
which they are not creating it.
But I think it's very similar to storytelling in every way.
And then we create, and then that, create that narrative,
and those sort of neural pathways get deeper and deeper and deeper those grooves.
And if you're, the danger is that if you don't do that,
我不是在提倡任何一种方式或什么，我真的没有立场，但如果你，那些事情变得如此之深，以至于那变成了你的，故事在你的脑海中根深蒂固，关于你是谁，我是这个，这就是方式，而且那通常会导致，我想随着你变老，你知道你，我知道我为自己说话，我对自己讲述的关于我是谁的故事已经很长时间了，变成了这个东西，我现在在这个年龄，快56岁了，想着，等等，我得，我得看看那个，因为我一直有这个叙事，而且我不是一个可靠的叙述者，你知道，真的，是啊，也不是，顺便说一下，任何13岁的孩子。
I'm not advocating either way or whatever, I don't have really a position,
but that if you, that those things get so deep that that becomes your,
story entrenched in your mind about who you are i am this this is the way and you can that can often
lead to i think as you get older you know you i know i know i speak for myself the story that i've been
telling myself about who i am for the longest time is become this thing that i've i'm like now at
this age almost 56 and going like wait i got to i got to look at that because i've been i've had this
narrative and i'm not a reliable narrator on this and you know truly yeah nor is ever
Any 13-year-old, by the way.
所以这是指责，有很多指责，对吧？当那个想法，即有一个煽动性的事件，某事发生在你身上，它带走了什么，它不计算的是思考方式。你如何，你知道，这是天性和养育。你是怎么出生的？我出生时比我妹妹有更焦虑的心态。而且我认为在你的童年，发生了A、B和C的想法，它可能涉及很多指责。
And so it's blame, there's a lot of blame, right?
When that idea that there is an inciting incident that something happened to you,
it takes away what it doesn't count is style of thinking.
How you, you know, it's nature and nurture.
How were you born?
I was born with a much more anxious mindset than my sister.
And I think the idea that in your childhood,
this A, B, and C happened, it can involve a lot of blame.
所以我认为对某些人来说，承担责任可能更难。我不知道这是否就是你所说的，威尔，就像你有点……是啊，我想是这样。我只是认为我们都有，首先，我们，每个人都有他们自己的化学构成。所以你可以有两个人，就像你说的，你和你妹妹，你可以有两个人，在同一个环境中长大，有同样的父母，同样的事情。他们完全不同。我们在我们自己的孩子身上看到了这一点。我当然在我的孩子身上看到了，他们对事情的反应不同。
And so I think it's maybe for some people harder to take accountability.
I don't know if that's that sort of what you're saying, Will, like you're sort of like...
Yeah, I think so.
I just think that we all have, first of all, we, everybody has their own sort of chemical makeup.
And so you can have two people, like you were saying, you and your sister, you can have two people who grew up in the same environment with the same parents, the same thing.
They're completely different.
We see it in our own kids.
I certainly see it in mine, and they react differently to stuff.
而且，在我的经验中，我长大了，我做事情的方式不同，这是真的。我直到现在这个年龄，才开始想，等一下，所有我以为的事情，比如，我早期没有那样做。我年轻时没有去接受精神分析。谢天谢地。好吧，也许，但现在我也得追溯性地，就像我更积极地在真正寻找去解锁很多，很多让我成为今天我的东西，好的和坏的，试图理解它一点，然后想，为什么我那样做？为什么我犯同样的错误？
And then, and it's true in my experience that I've grown up and I do things differently.
And I'm only now at this age, started to go like, wait a second, all the stuff that I thought, like, I didn't do that early on.
I didn't go to psychoanalysis when I was young.
Thank God.
Well, maybe, but also now I got to sort of retroactively, like I'm much more actively really searching to try to unlock a lot.
lot of the stuff that made me who I am today good and bad in trying to understand it a little bit
and go like, why do I do that?
Why do I make the same mistakes?
为什么我做这些事情？好人。是啊，有足够的自我意识去想弄清楚它，比只是随波逐流要好。对。也许你只是没有你现在拥有的情感智力去真正做大量的深入和诚实的分析和内省。你知道，所以，你知道，好时机。你准备好了就准备好了。
Why do I do this stuff?
Good man.
Yeah, it's better to be self-aware enough to want to figure it out than just float along.
Right.
And maybe you just wouldn't have had the emotional intelligence that you have now to really do a lot of deep
and honest analysis and introspection.
You know, so it's, you know, good time.
You're ready when you're ready.
是啊。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。好吧，阿曼达，说到，现在保持深入和沉重。哦，该死，抱歉，上帝。不。当你……当你扮演角色和类似的事情时呢？
Yeah.
We'll be right back.
And now back to the show.
Well, Amanda, speaking on, keeping it deep and heavy now.
Oh, shit, sorry, God.
No.
What about when you're-
What about when you're playing parts and stuff like that?
你是在享受、探索和利用你身上所有不同的部分，并将它们注入到这些角色中吗？我现在太他妈喜欢演戏了。还是你喜欢扮演完全不同的人？哦，我什么都做。我两者都喜欢。对，但我是说，什么是，什么是，什么是你的策略？比如，你是在想，好吧，我如何创造一个完全不同的人，或者，好吧，我在这个角色中认出了我自己的一部分？
Are you enjoying and exploring and utilizing all the different parts of you
and injecting them into these characters?
I am so fucking into acting right now.
Or do you like playing completely different people?
Oh, I'll do anything.
I like both.
Right, but I mean, what is, what is, what's like your, what's like your strategy?
Like, are you, are you, do you think about, okay, how do I create an entirely different person or, okay, I recognize a part of myself in this character?
所以让我们探索我自己的那一部分，我们就会叫她这个角色叫什么名字？好吧，我现在在这个时刻主要被赋予的角色，可能更像我。是的，有时候当我在拍摄前，如果我发现自己在想如何，试图表现得好。对。如果我想，就像，我在尝试，如果我。那类似于，那类似于试图表现得好或者思考如何扮演它吗？
And so let's explore that part of myself and we'll just call her whatever this character.
characters called?
Well, I'm mostly given parts right now at this moment that are more, probably more like me.
And yes, sometimes when right before I do a take, if I catch myself thinking about how to,
trying to be good.
Right.
If I think, like, I'm trying, if I.
Is that similar to, is that similar to try to be good or thinking about how to play it?
是的，就像编排任何事情。编排一个结果。是的。对。我试着假装大卫或莎拉·保尔森在视频村。他们会说这是胡扯。而且他们会说这是胡扯。所以我说，好吧，现在你必须做一个，他们必须，
Yes, like orchestrating anything.
Orchestrating a result.
Yes.
Right.
I try to pretend that David or Sarah Paulson are there at the video village.
They'll call bullshit.
And that they'll call bullshit.
So I say, okay, now you have to do one where they have to,
他们将不得不猜测它是真的还是假的。它是真的你还是不是真的你。那太棒了。这就是这一刻的策略。是啊，因为很多演员……工作得如此努力，让你知道他们没有在演戏，以至于看起来像在演戏。哦，你是对的？是啊。
they're going to have to guess whether it's real or not real.
Whether it's really you or not really you.
That's awesome.
And that's the strategy for this moment.
Yeah, because a lot of actors...
work so hard to let you know they're not acting that it looks like acting.
Oh, you're right?
Yeah.
而如果你专注于只是像为微观镜头表演，对某些人来说，那是他们自己，对吧？比如，对我来说，就是这种情况。比如，我知道我会看我在这里的表演，我将无法逃脱任何事情。你知道，我不会给自己任何形式的，你知道，解脱。比如，它必须是超级，你知道，比如，我在看。对你来说，那个显微镜是大卫和莎拉。
Whereas if you focus on just like performing for one microscopic lens that, for some
people, it's themselves, right?
Like, for me, it's that case.
Like, I know I'm going to watch my performance here and I'm not going to be able to
get away with anything.
You know, I'm not going to give myself any sort of, you know, relief.
Like, it's got to be super, you know, like, I'm watching.
For you, that microscope is David and Sarah.
从来不是阿曼达。嗯？从来不是我最好的朋友阿曼达？不，我可以欺骗阿曼达。我可以欺骗她。别这样。不，你不能。不，我不能。
It's never Amanda.
Huh?
It's never my best friend, Amanda?
No, I can trick Amanda.
I can trick her.
Stop it.
No, you can't.
No, I can't.
另一个阿曼达，抱歉，为了清楚起见，另一个阿曼达。哦，抱歉，我和J.B.的妻子阿曼达很亲近。我们可以和另一个阿曼达谈谈吗？阿曼达·熊猫。不，阿曼达和杰森一起演了什么电影？有两个，对吧？是只有两个还是更多？
The other Amanda, sorry, just to be clear,
the other Amanda.
Oh, sorry, I'm very close with J.B.'s wife, Amanda.
Can we talk to the other Amanda?
Amanda Panda.
No, Amanda and Jason were in what movie together?
There were two, right?
Was it just two or was it more?
哦，天哪，哦，天哪，我忘了那个……我忘了那个人。我是说，她以《南波士顿》出道，而她忘了你的事。是啊，谢谢。你忘了哪一个？你把水泥浇在哪个上面了？我忘了轮椅那个。
Oh, God, oh my God, I forgot about the...
I forgot about the person.
I mean, she came out of the gate with Sauty,
and she forgot about your shit.
Yeah, thanks.
Which one did you forget about?
Which one did you pour cement over?
I forgot about the wheelchair one.
你不记得标题了吗？哦，我知道那个。我们等着。哦，天哪。事实上，我想它是……我也记得那个。是啊，它最初叫什么？阿米斯滕也在里面，对吧？
Do you don't remember the title?
Oh, I know that one.
We'll wait.
Oh, my God.
In fact, I think it was...
I remember that one, too.
Yeah, what was it originally called?
With Armistens in that, too, right?
那是查尔斯·格罗丁在里面的那个吗？我无法和他演戏，因为他太搞笑了。它以《X》的名字发行。哦，对了。但它最初叫什么？我想它最初有一个更好的名字。导演的名字是什么？
Is that the one in Charles,
Groton?
I couldn't act with him because he was too funny.
It was released as the X.
Oh, that's right.
But what was it called originally?
I think it had a better name originally.
What was the director's name?
杰西·佩雷茨？是啊，杰西·佩雷茨。看着我。我不敢相信你知道那个。看看你。我知道。好吧，艾米在里面，对吧？艾米在里面，是啊。
Jesse Peretz?
Yeah, Jesse Peretz.
Look at me.
I can't believe you know that.
Look at you.
I know.
Well, Amy was in it, right?
Amy was in it, yeah.
肖恩，你没看吗？我有时间，我得到了我的提示。我演了一个坐轮椅的混蛋。阿曼达和我演……离那还有一周。我们演……我们演……我们演前男友，女朋友，或者那种我以前想让你做我女朋友。
Sean, you didn't see it?
I had time I, I took my cue.
I played an asshole in a wheelchair.
And Amanda and I play...
A week away from that.
We play...
We play ex-boyfriend, girlfriend, or kind of I wanted you to be my girlfriend back in the day.
但现在我们后来在生活中相遇了。我们以前在啦啦队里，当时我想让你做我女朋友。哦，天哪。肖恩笑了。是啊。哇，肖恩。电影里有一个时刻，我在轮椅上，我们看到了对方。我说，嘿，你吗？
But now we meet up later in life.
And we were on cheer team together when I wanted you to be my girlfriend.
Oh, my God.
Sean laughs.
Yeah.
Wow, Sean.
And there's a moment in the film where I'm in my wheelchair and we see each other.
And I go, hey, do you?
嘿。我说，嘿，记得那个动作吗？我用一只手臂把你举过头顶，作为一个座位。你坐在我举过头顶的手上，而我坐在椅子上。我们，我们真的那样做了，不是吗？还是你在缆绳上？我觉得我们可能真的那样做了。缆绳，为什么？
Hey.
And I say, hey, remember the move?
and I lift you up over my head with one arm as a seat.
You're sitting on my hand up over my head as I'm sitting in the chair.
Did we, we did that for real, didn't we?
Or were you on cables?
I feel like we may have done it for real.
Cables, why?
因为你的手，你的手臂太细了。我是说，我见过你几乎萎缩的手臂。我不觉得那很可怜。是啊，我不能和我的孩子们那样做。但我感觉我们可能……不，我们一遍又一遍地排练。我们真的那样做了，不是吗？是啊，我们做了。
Because your hand, your arm is so fine.
I mean, I've seen your nearly atrophied arms.
I don't think that's pathetic.
Yeah, I couldn't do that with my children.
But I feel like we may have...
No, we rehearsed over and over again.
We did that for real, didn't we?
Yeah, we did.
你的意思是，没有几个穿着绿色套装的场务举着她？现在，他们必须得那样。但那是……那非常有趣。是啊，查尔斯·格罗丁。我爱查尔斯·格罗丁。然后我们拍了《身份窃贼》。是的。
You mean there weren't a couple grips wearing green suits holding her?
Nowadays, they'd have to.
But it was...
That was very fun.
Yeah, Charles Groden.
I love Charles Groen.
And then we did Identity Thief.
Yes.
记得那个吗？我当然记得。关于那个我记得最清楚的事情是阿曼达在酒店给MAPs喂奶。是的。这就是我记得的。杰森的阿曼达。再说一次，这说明了很多关于你的演技，杰米。这就是她记得的。
Remember that one?
I sure do.
The thing I remember about that the most is Amanda breastfeeding MAPs in the hotel.
Yes.
That's what I remember.
Jason's Amanda.
Again, it says a lot about your acting, Jamie.
That's what she remembers.
那是一个伟大的，那是一部伟大的电影。我爱那个身份窃贼。是啊，那是一部伟大的电影。在那上面太有趣了。麦卡锡女士表现得太棒了。好吧。让我们回到开始。让我们稍微过一遍。
That's a great, that was a great movie.
I love that identity thing.
Yeah, it's a great movie.
So much fun on that.
Ms. McCarthy crushing it.
All right.
Let's get back to the beginning.
Let's roll through this a little bit.
我们要加快速度了。我们做了太多的时间废话。你在纽约市长大。你在纽约出生，在纽约长大，对吧？在纽约上学。出生长大。你在城市哪里长大的？
We're going to pick up the pace here.
We're doing so much time bullshit.
You grew up in New York City.
You were born in New York,
grew up in New York, right?
Went to school in New York.
Born raised.
Where did you grow up in the city?
在曼哈顿？在曼哈顿，是啊。哦，我们在11街和5大道。哦，看看那个。什么是仍然是你日常行为一部分的最纽约的东西？哦，那是个好问题。你觉得你，因为你在那里住了一段时间？
In Manhattan?
In Manhattan, yeah.
Oh, we're 11th and 5th.
Oh, look at that.
What is the most New York thing
that is still a part of your everyday behavior?
Oh, that's a good question.
What do you think you, because you lived there for a while?
我在这里工作。对。是啊。那个城市在你的个性中赋予了你什么东西？精神分析，当然。是啊，是啊。每个人都在那里向内看。百吉饼。
I'm working here.
Right.
Yeah.
What would be the thing that that city gifted you in your persona?
Psychoanalysis, of course.
Yeah, yeah.
Everybody's looking inside over there.
Bagels.
是啊，当你离开纽约市时，你最想念什么？只是整个麦吉利卡迪，地铁，和其他人肩并肩。是啊。你现在在哪里？那是错的，我提到了，哦，天哪，我在卧室里。
Yeah, when you leave New York City, what do you miss the most?
Just the whole McGillicuddy, the subway, the rubbing shoulders with other people.
Yeah.
Where are you right now?
That was by mistake
I mentioned
Oh God
I'm in the bedroom
我是说你在纽约还是洛杉矶？哦，抱歉，哦，抱歉，上帝。我在洛杉矶。是啊，我们现在住在洛杉矶。是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。好吧，所以你刚开始。
I mean are you in New York
or Los Angeles
Oh sorry
Jesus I'm in Los Angeles
Yeah we live in Los Angeles now
Yeah yeah yeah yeah
All right so you're starting out
我的意思是，你是在纽约还是洛杉矶？哦，抱歉，哦，抱歉，天哪，我在洛杉矶。是的，我们现在住在洛杉矶。对，对，对，对。好吧，所以你刚开始起步。
JBA are we on a snack break
I'm sorry
That's the last fight
I thought I moved the microphone
Far enough away
I apologize
What is happening
So you grew up in New York
JBA，我们是在吃零食休息吗？抱歉，那是最后一次争吵，我以为我已经把麦克风移得够远了。我道歉，这到底是怎么回事？所以你是在纽约长大的。
And you say to your
And your parents are a million miles from showbiz, and you go, hey, I think I'm going to be an actor.
Now, were you doing any sort of like jobs before you got started that maybe you could say, well, but I'm, this is kind of taken off for me and I won't have to be doing X anymore.
No, I was doing school plays.
I did all the school plays.
And because I went to a tiny Quaker school,
I was, you know, one of the best singers there,
which is saying nothing.
你说你的父母离演艺圈有十万八千里远，然后你说，嘿，我想当个演员。在你开始之前，你有没有做过什么工作，让你觉得，嗯，这对我来说已经有起色了，我不用再做X了？没有，我当时在参加学校的戏剧演出。我参加了所有的学校戏剧。因为我上的是一所很小的贵格会学校，我是那里最好的歌手之一，但这其实说明不了什么。
Right.
And it was a short order, not a tall order.
And then as soon as I got to college,
I started, I sort of walked in confidently to all these auditions,
and I never got a single play.
I auditioned for 20 plays, yeah.
Oh, wow.
Really?
对。那是个小任务，不是什么艰巨的任务。然后我一上大学，就开始自信满满地去参加各种试镜，结果一次都没选上。我试镜了20部戏，真的。哦，哇。真的吗？
It was as if they had already decided
they already had their own click.
Yeah, they were like, no, no, these parts are reserved for people who were good.
Were you not studying drama?
Did you...
I took a teenage acting class that my mom found for me starting when I was 13, too,
as well as being in psychoanalysis.
No, but what about college?
就好像他们已经决定好他们自己的小圈子了。是的，他们就像是，不，不，这些角色是留给那些优秀的人的。你当时没学戏剧吗？你……我从13岁开始就参加了我妈帮我找的青少年表演班，同时也一直在接受心理分析。不，我是说大学呢？
Where was that? Where was that? Where was that acting school?
Where was 13?
That was at HB Studios.
So eventually my teacher...
HB Studios!
Yes.
What's the half?
Yeah, as a lot of actors get there started.
那是在哪？那是在哪？那个表演学校在哪？13岁的时候是在哪？那是在HB工作室。所以后来我的老师……HB工作室！是的。那个“半”是什么意思？是的，很多演员都是从那里开始的。
Eventually, my teacher said, you know, you really need to study with Uta Hagen.
And so my junior year at college, I auditioned for Uta Hagen.
Now, what about in, so in college, were you studying drama?
No, I was studying American history.
Yeah.
So never went into the drama program.
Because I bet if you joined the drama program, they might have felt obligated to put you in a play.
There wasn't a drama program.
后来，我的老师说，你知道，你真的需要跟乌塔·哈根（Uta Hagen）学习。所以大三的时候，我参加了乌塔·哈根的试镜。那么，在大学里，你是在学戏剧吗？没有，我学的是美国历史。是的。所以从来没进过戏剧专业。因为我敢打赌，如果你加入了戏剧专业，他们可能会觉得有义务让你演戏。当时根本没有戏剧专业。
What's happening, Sean?
That's Scotty.
Oh, that's Scotty.
He's just striking the set.
He's just striking.
Yeah, I said we're just striking the set.
All right, so then you start auditioning.
Well, okay, so college starts to beat you up a little bit
怎么了，肖恩？那是斯科蒂。哦，那是斯科蒂。他只是在拆卸布景。他只是在拆卸。是的，我说我们只是在拆卸布景。好吧，所以你开始试镜了。好吧，所以大学开始让你有点受挫了。
and tax your confidence.
Meanwhile, you're like, I audition for 20 plays.
I'm not getting anything.
This is for me.
Like, what's the, what's the thing?
Did you go out and get an agent?
How did you start auditioning?
I hadn't really admitted it quite yet.
并且打击了你的自信心。同时，你心想，我试镜了20部戏。我什么都没得到。这不适合我。就像，到底是怎么回事？你有没有出去找个经纪人？你是怎么开始试镜的？我当时还没完全承认这一点。
I still think, and I had, it's almost like, you know,
what people say like, you know, like a self-hating Jew or something like that.
I was like a self-hating actor.
I couldn't quite admit that I wanted to actually do this as more than a hobby.
And was it the same for you, Sean?
Oh, no, I'm just enraptu.
Oh, I thought you were like, yes, I relate to that.
Yeah, no, I'm just like, yeah.
我仍然认为，而且我有，这几乎就像，你知道，人们所说的，你知道，像个自我厌恶的犹太人什么的。我当时就像个自我厌恶的演员。我无法完全承认我真的想把这当作爱好以外的事情来做。你也是这样吗，肖恩？哦，不，我只是入迷了。哦，我以为你会说，是的，我对此很有共鸣。是的，不，我只是，是的。
Oh, no, Sean was a prodigy.
No, no, I mean a little bit, yeah.
Well, you know, when you're young, you never think you're good, you know?
Like you're just like hanging on by a thread.
I mean,
I've never been more confident than when I was young.
And then I go old enough to realize,
oh no, Jason, you're full of shit.
哦，不，肖恩是个天才。不，不，我是说有一点，是的。嗯，你知道，当你年轻的时候，你从不认为自己很棒，你知道吗？就像你只是在悬崖边挣扎。我的意思是，我年轻时从未像那时那样自信。然后我长大了，意识到，哦不，杰森，你满嘴胡言。
But also because you worked all the time.
Like I had this similar.
I moved to New York and I didn't get anything for years.
Like, why the fuck did I keep doing it?
Yeah.
Nobody wanted to hire me for anything.
But Amanda, you went out,
but Amanda at some point you went out and got an agent, right?
但也因为你一直在工作。就像我有过类似的经历。我搬到纽约，好几年什么都没得到。就像，我他妈为什么要一直坚持下去？是的。没人想雇我做任何事。但是阿曼达，你出去了，但阿曼达在某个时候你出去找了个经纪人，对吧？
And you started auditioning?
Yeah. So then once I was in Uta's class,
I was in an adult class at age.
18 and so people had
headshots and agents and they taught
me what the
backstage magazine but also
the Ross reports where you could look up
然后你开始试镜了？是的。所以一旦我进了乌塔的班，我在18岁时就参加了成人班，所以人们都有头像照和经纪人，他们教我什么是《后台》杂志，还有罗斯报告，你可以在那里查到……
there was a little booklet and it had every agent in New York
City and I just would start crossing them out
and I would take the subway and go to make a day
make submissions and I would go in person
with like full makeup
yeah you had to want it right and
and slip my headshot under the same
and they'd be like thank you
有一本小册子，上面有纽约市所有的经纪人，我就开始把他们划掉，然后我坐地铁去进行一天的投递，我会亲自去，化着全妆，是的，你必须想要它，对吧，然后把我的头像照塞进门下，他们就会说，谢谢。
We got it.
Stop pushing it under the door.
Stop pushing it.
Yeah, we don't take unsolicited headshots.
You know what?
I've never told anybody this story.
This is absolutely true when I was like 23.
And I had like a headshot.
我们收到了。别再往里塞了。别再塞了。是的，我们不接受未经请求的头像照。你知道吗？我从来没跟任何人讲过这个故事。这是千真万确的，当我大概23岁的时候。我有一张头像照。
It was just terrible.
And like nothing of fake resume.
Did you look worse than you look now?
Can you put your hands for your hair please?
Sorry.
Fix it.
It's off your forehair.
There you go.
简直太糟糕了。而且什么都没有，简历也是假的。你当时看起来比现在更糟吗？请把你的手从头发上拿开好吗？抱歉。整理一下。把它从额头上弄开。好了。
It's cute.
Pethead.
And I went up to 30 Rock.
This is before the advent of like high security.
and stuff.
And I went to 30 Rock.
And I went, it might have been even 92.
And I went in and I got on the elevator and I went up and I put my resume on the desk at 8H.
很可爱。宠物头。然后我去了洛克菲勒中心30号。这是在高安保措施出现之前。之类的。我去了洛克菲勒中心30号。我去了，那可能甚至是92年。我走进去，上了电梯，我上去了，把我的简历放在了8H的桌子上。
At SNL?
At SNL.
Honey, not everybody knows what fucking 8H is.
I'm sorry.
To be a spoken by Studio 60.
I actually didn't know that.
And have they called?
So you thought you were funny.
在《周六夜现场》（SNL）？在《周六夜现场》。亲爱的，不是每个人都知道他妈的8H是什么。抱歉。应该说是60号演播室。我其实不知道那个。他们打过电话吗？所以你以为你很有趣。
I don't know.
I mean, you're right.
But I just...
But talk about confident and unwarranted.
So you wanted to be on SNL early.
I thought about it, but I had no...
I didn't do sketch or anything.
Anyway, this interview was not about me.
我不知道。我的意思是，你是对的。但我只是……但谈谈自信和毫无根据。所以你很早就想上《周六夜现场》了。我想过，但我没有……我没做过小品什么的。总之，这次采访不是关于我的。
But I did go and do that same thing.
I went and I put the thing on, embarrassingly enough.
I just had this image of me sliding my...
Just like you said, Amanda,
sliding my headshot and resume underneath the door,
waiting three seconds, and it just comes right back.
With a bunch of piss on it.
No, just a big sharpie on it.
但我确实去做了同样的事情。我去了，把那个东西放进去，尴尬的是。我脑子里一直有那个画面，我滑着……就像你说的，阿曼达，把我的头像照和简历滑到门下，等三秒钟，它就直接被退回来了。上面还带着一堆尿。不，只是上面用大号记号笔写着字。
the outside of the envelope.
And you guys,
you guys, not only that,
but eventually,
so I auditioned for agents,
you know, like I did monologues
in their offices,
and eventually I got repped,
信封外面。你们，你们，不仅如此，最终，我参加了经纪人的试镜，你知道，我在他们的办公室里表演独白，最终我签了经纪人。
and the teen rep
walked me to the corner
of 57th and 7th
with one of her colleagues
and said,
and she was saying,
congratulations, we want to rep you,
and was sort of giving me
然后青少年经纪人带着我和她的一个同事走到57街和7大道的拐角处，说，她在说，恭喜，我们想签你，并且在某种程度上给我……
the lay of the land,
and then was like,
um,
and the other thing,
we just wanted to know,
so for your,
you have a little bit of, you got a mustache a little bit here.
We're just wondering what can we do about that.
介绍了一下情况，然后说，嗯，还有一件事，我们只是想知道，所以对于你的，你这里有一点，你这里有一点胡子。我们只是想知道我们能对此做些什么。
Oh my God.
What?
Oh, my God.
Was she right?
She was right.
Really?
Oh, my God.
Wait a second.
天哪。什么？天哪。她是认真的吗？她是认真的。真的吗？天哪。等一下。
So how old are you?
Don't name her, but what agency?
What agency was that?
It was S-T-E at the time.
It became paradigm.
How old?
Right.
18.
所以你多大？别说出她的名字，但哪家经纪公司？那是哪家经纪公司？当时是S-T-E。后来变成了Paradigm。多大？对。18岁。
19.
You were 18.
And you had a little bit of a fuzz there.
And, and.
Wow.
I think it must have been more than a fuzz
because I've seen a fuzz.
19岁。你当时18岁。19岁。你那里有一点绒毛。而且，而且。哇。我想那肯定不止是绒毛，因为我见过绒毛。
Okay.
What was the strategy on removal?
Was it bleaching or waxing?
She's like, no, watch this.
I'm going to grow it out.
Take that.
What was this?
What was this strategy?
好吧。去除的策略是什么？是漂白还是打蜡？她说，不，看着这个。我要把它留长。拿去吧。这是什么？这是什么策略？
Jamie wants to get it.
No, I want an answer to that.
Did we bleach it or did we wax it?
We did everything.
We did nearing.
We did bleach.
We did fucking, you fucking name it.
Yeah.
杰米想知道。不，我想要个答案。我们是漂白了还是打蜡了？我们什么都做了。我们做了针头脱毛。我们做了漂白。我们做了他妈的，你他妈能想到的都做了。是的。
Wow.
Isn't that something?
I would pay so much money to see my face and see myself try to handle that.
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
And be like, oh, yeah, yeah.
Was that so.
I had an agent recommended nutritionist to me once.
哇。那不是很有趣吗？我会花很多钱去看我的脸，看我自己试图处理那个。是的。嗯哼。然后说，哦，是的，是的。那是这样吗。我曾经有个经纪人给我推荐过营养师。
Oh.
Yeah.
And I was like, this was last week?
Got it.
About 18 months ago.
I know the guys of it.
It did a lot for me and I was like, cool.
Hey, I had a really big.
哦。是的。我说，这是上周的事？明白了。大约18个月前。我知道其中的门道。它对我帮助很大，我就想，酷。嘿，我有一个非常大的。
big shot agent not too long ago pitch to another person that I work with say, hey, if it's ever
appropriate and you feel like you can kind of squeeze it into the conversation, ask Jason if he'd
ever consider highlights.
If he had highlights, it would really open things up for sort of like real sexy kind of
leading man.
And I was like, motherfucker.
Are you serious?
Did you do it?
大牌经纪人不久前向我合作的另一个人推销，说，嘿，如果合适的话，你觉得可以把它塞进谈话里，问问杰森是否会考虑挑染。如果他挑染了，那真的会打开局面，变成那种真正性感的主角类型。我就想，你这混蛋。你是认真的吗？你做了吗？
Studio exact.
No, no, agent.
King, King agent.
And did you do it or no?
No, I did not, Shawnee.
I have not colored my hair since the incredible Frank Stallone vehicle Philly Boy on CBS in 1990.
You have so few grays, too.
You have so few grays.
工作室高管。不，不，经纪人。大牌经纪人。你做了吗，还是没做？不，我没做，肖尼。自从1990年在哥伦比亚广播公司播出的那部不可思议的弗兰克·斯塔龙主演的《费城男孩》之后，我就没染过头发。你的白发也太少了。你的白发太少了。
It's so.
They're coming.
I do feel like they're coming.
There are a few that are trying to fight their way.
Okay, so wait.
Now, so you get this note about.
the stash, you're addressing it,
are you feeling like, yes, this is great, this is a good
太……它们要来了。我确实觉得它们要来了。有几根正在试图挣扎出来。好吧，等等。现在，所以你得到了关于胡子的那个建议，你在处理它，你感觉像是，是的，这太棒了，这是一个好的……
thing, or wait a second, is that what this
business is going to be? My feelings are hurt.
I'm not getting a lot of stuff, even though I
just got a new, I should quit.
Did you ever feel like quitting at any moment
in your career?
I think more later,
I think it was more
事情，还是等一下，这就是这个行业的样子吗？我的感情受到了伤害。我没得到很多东西，尽管我刚得到一个新的，我应该辞职。你职业生涯中有没有哪一刻想过辞职？我觉得是后来，我觉得更多是……
later. I think that...
Because the opportunities weren't what they were
what you wanted or it was just like, oh,
I'm good. I have nothing left to prove to myself.
I've had incredible success and
next.
It sure wasn't that, Jason.
Well, it could be.
后来。我觉得……因为机会不是你想要的，或者只是，哦，我很好。我没什么需要向自己证明的了。我已经取得了不可思议的成功，下一个。肯定不是那样，杰森。嗯，可能是。
I've had an incredible success.
I'm going to go rest on my laurels now.
I completed everything.
Take another look.
Yeah, I think, well, you know, like once I started writing a little bit,
and when I was shooting the chair, which, you know, when I was behind the camera and all
the ladies, like Sandra O and everyone had to get there earlier, and I could roll in in my
snow pants with my mustache and my hair and just be and but still be the boss i was like this is
我已经取得了不可思议的成功。我现在要去躺在功劳簿上休息了。我完成了一切。再看一眼。是的，我想，嗯，你知道，一旦我开始写一点东西，当我拍摄《主席》的时候，你知道，当我在摄像机后面，所有的女士们，比如吴珊卓和每个人都必须早点到，我可以穿着我的雪裤，留着我的胡子和头发，就这样，但仍然是老板，我就想，这……
fucking great what have i been doing this whole time right and then yeah that's okay so then that so then
the latter and it's really fun to have you know to have last cut final cut right well let's let's let's
let's talk about that let's talk about how did how did the chair come into your orbit so so so folks she was
the creator, the writer, the showrunner
for the Netflix series
called The Chair, starring Sandra O.
And so was this,
how did it come to you? Tell us about that.
他妈的太棒了，我这整段时间都在干什么，对吧？然后是的，没关系，所以那个，所以那个后者，拥有最后的剪辑权真的很棒，对吧？好吧，让我们谈谈那个，让我们谈谈《主席》是怎么进入你的轨道的。所以，所以，所以各位，她是Netflix剧集《主席》的创作者、编剧、剧集主管，由吴珊卓主演。所以这是，它是怎么找到你的？告诉我们关于那个。
Because I went to friends
in Manhattan on 16th Street
and there was a teacher who was there
when I was there, who was really lovely.
And in the New York Times,
it was in the New York Times,
there was a huge Michigas
because he was in a math class
因为我去了曼哈顿16街的朋友学校，那里有一位老师，我在那里的时候他也在，他真的很可爱。在《纽约时报》上，在《纽约时报》上，有一场巨大的骚乱，因为他在数学课上……
and he was pointing
to something and he was,
He made a Nazi salute joke.
Who's he?
It was the teacher.
And it became at Friends Seminary at my Quaker school, this huge controversy.
Friends is a school.
他指着什么东西，他，他开了一个纳粹礼的玩笑。他是谁？是那个老师。这在我的贵格会学校——朋友神学院，成了一场巨大的争议。朋友学校是一所学校。朋友学校是一所学校。
Manhattan Friends is a Quaker school.
And it was the beginning of...
It's a joke. You broke. Your love life's D-O-A.
O-A. Yeah.
You know.
I can't believe they still go there.
All those six friends.
Jen's going to figure it out.
曼哈顿朋友学校是一所贵格会学校。那是……的开始。这是一个笑话。你破产了。你的爱情生活死定了。是的。你知道。我不敢相信他们还在那里上学。所有那六个朋友。简会弄明白的。
Sorry. Go ahead.
I like this idea of having a woman of color
who was the boss of a white dude who transgresses.
And it was sort of the beginning of cancel culture
and all that stuff.
And I knew this teacher to be a lovely, kind,
Quaker-leaning human being.
And the fact that he's incited this whole controversy,
抱歉。继续。我喜欢这个想法，让一个有色人种女性成为一个越界的白人男性的老板。这在某种程度上是取消文化和所有这些东西的开始。我知道这位老师是一个可爱、善良、倾向于贵格会的人。事实上他引发了这场巨大的争议，
I thought this is such a good story.
What, can I ask, what's a Quaker?
I mean, I know what a Quaker is.
I know what Quaker oats are.
Yeah, that's all I know.
But what's a Quaker school?
What does it mean?
You know, it's a Christian denomination, but I feel like they're the greatest.
我觉得这是一个很好的故事。我可以问一下，什么是贵格会吗？我的意思是，我知道什么是贵格会。我知道什么是贵格燕麦。是的，我只知道这些。但什么是贵格会学校？那意味着什么？你知道，这是一个基督教教派，但我觉得他们是最棒的。
They really take the word literally.
So, you know, there's no priesthood.
You know, in a Quaker meeting house, anyone is allowed, regardless of your religion.
There's no priesthood because the idea is nobody is closer to God than anybody else.
Oh, got it.
It's called a popcorn meeting when someone stands up and speaks because anyone...
Also great fiber.
You want to talk about a denomination that's got colon health?
他们真的按字面意思理解这个词。所以，你知道，没有神职人员。你知道，在贵格会的聚会所里，任何人都可以，不管你的宗教信仰如何。没有神职人员，因为理念是没人比其他人更接近上帝。哦，明白了。当有人站起来发言时，这被称为爆米花聚会，因为任何人……还有很好的纤维。你想谈谈一个关注结肠健康的教派吗？
You need to go no further.
Oh, was I getting boring?
Was I getting like...
Yeah, that's our job.
We got to pop it in every once in a while.
Yeah, yeah.
Hey, but tell me what...
Poop farts.
你不需要再找了。哦，我是不是变得很无聊？我是不是变得……是的，那是我们的工作。我们得时不时地插一句。是的，是的。嘿，但告诉我什么……屁。
Mustaches.
You got to do it.
We're just dumb dudes.
Hey, what about...
What made you think that you could be the boss?
Nothing.
Yeah.
The writer.
胡子。你得做。我们只是笨蛋。嘿，关于……是什么让你觉得你可以当老板？没什么。是的。编剧。
Yeah.
Nothing.
What made you think?
But everyone would love to like
Would like to have their own show on Netflix
I mean like how great
Well first of all I watched David and Dan do it
是的。没什么。是的。是什么让你觉得？但每个人都想，就像，想在Netflix上有自己的节目，我的意思是，多棒啊。嗯，首先，我看着大卫和丹做到了。
Yeah and you're like
These two guys can yeah
Yeah
Holy shit
Exactly
No I was like oh my god I better not fuck this up
I think it's just like love of actors
That was it
是的，你就像，这两个家伙可以，是的，是的，天哪，完全正确。不，我就想，哦天哪，我最好别搞砸了。我觉得这就像对演员的热爱。就是那样。
That was like my starting point
Scary though right
Clearly immense writing talent
and we're going to get into that.
But like, where did the writing talent come from?
You didn't study it in school.
I did.
You did?
那是我的起点。很可怕，对吧？显然有巨大的写作天赋，我们会深入探讨这一点。但是，写作天赋是从哪里来的？你没在学校学过。我学过。你学过？
Okay.
Yeah.
American history and American culture.
Well, I just took a lot of creative writing classes.
Okay.
And then acting just sort of took over,
but I was always kind of dabbling.
And then I think when I married David,
好的。是的。美国历史和美国文化。嗯，我只是上了很多创意写作课。好的。然后表演就接管了一切，但我一直都在涉猎。然后我想当我嫁给大卫时，
he was really encouraging.
When Studio 60 got canceled,
he was like, take a step.
Let's go.
Yeah.
Especially you, and that was.
Aaron Sorkin, wasn't it?
So you had, you had, you'd just been under that.
他真的很鼓励我。《60号演播室》被取消时，他说，迈出一步。我们走吧。是的。尤其是你，那是。艾伦·索金，不是吗？所以你，你，你刚在那下面。
I mean, my God, those, yeah, those scripts.
Incredible.
So wait, all right, while we're on the writing thing,
let's talk about this incredible essay
that was just published by the New Yorker
a couple of weeks ago.
If you haven't read it or looked for it, do so.
It is, I mean, you tell me, Amanda,
我的天哪，那些，是的，那些剧本。不可思议。所以等等，好吧，当我们谈论写作的时候，让我们谈谈几周前《纽约客》刚刚发表的那篇不可思议的文章。如果你还没读过或者找过它，一定要去看看。它是，我的意思是，你告诉我，阿曼达，
is this not the equivalent of, of an,
Oscar for an actor to be a writer and to get published in the New Yorker is the zenith of accomplishments.
I lost my mind.
I can't wait to read this.
What's the name of the article?
It doesn't have a name.
It's...
But what would you name it?
这难道不是相当于，一个演员的奥斯卡奖吗？作为一个作家，能在《纽约客》上发表文章是成就的巅峰。我疯了。我迫不及待想读它。那篇文章叫什么名字？它没有名字。它是……但你会给它起什么名字？
No, I mean, like, how do I find it?
Just Amanda Pete New Yorker?
Yeah.
Oh, there's a start.
Have you ever used the internet?
Sorry, I should say.
I have read it and it is, not only is it an incredible piece of writing, but the subject matter, it is, it is nonfiction.
不，我的意思是，我怎么找到它？只是阿曼达·皮特《纽约客》？是的。哦，那是个开始。是的。你用过互联网吗？抱歉，我应该说。我已经读过了，它不仅是一篇不可思议的文章，而且主题，它是，它是非虚构的。
It is, it is about our guest and her family and mortality.
And tell them the rest of it if you're comfortable because it is just stunning.
And it left me with real wet cheeks at the end.
Thank you, J.B.
And I mean facial cheeks.
Sorry, I need to be clear.
Will, where is your thing or d'ar?
I know it's so far away.
它是，它是关于我们的嘉宾和她的家人以及死亡。如果你觉得舒服的话，告诉他们剩下的部分，因为它太震撼了。最后让我脸颊湿透了。谢谢你，J.B.。我的意思是脸颊。抱歉，我需要说清楚。威尔，你的东西在哪？我知道它太远了。
You missed it.
Hang on a second.
Jason, just say facial cheeks.
And I had, and I ended with real wet cheeks afterwards.
Facial cheeks.
The boys will put that together.
I don't believe that actually work.
And we will be right back.
你错过了。等一下。杰森，就说脸颊。之后我脸颊湿透了。脸颊。男孩们会把那个拼凑起来的。我不相信那真的有效。我们马上回来。
And now back to the show.
Amanda, tell us about some of the things that are revealed in this.
I mean, deeply, deeply personal.
Well, so on the Friday of Labor Day weekend, this last Labor Day weekend,
I went to my breast surgeon.
I have what's known as dense and busy breasts.
Guys, I'm not going to hit that softball.
You all leave that to you guys.
现在回到节目。阿曼达，告诉我们这里面揭示的一些事情。我的意思是，非常非常私人的。嗯，所以劳动节周末的周五，上个劳动节周末，我去了我的乳腺外科医生那里。我有所谓的致密且繁忙的乳房。伙计们，我不会去接那个软球。你们留给你们自己吧。
Keep your finger-dinger near by.
I feel like you were looking at my search history.
Okay.
You really teed that up.
No, you guys, for real, it's a real thing.
And it means you have to get tested all the time.
Do you mind telling me what, because I'm super into medical stuff.
把你的手指放在附近。我觉得你在看我的搜索记录。好的。你真的把它架起来了。好的。不，伙计们，说真的，这是真实的事情。这意味着你必须一直做检查。你不介意告诉我什么，因为我对医学的东西超级感兴趣。
Like, what is that condition?
What is, if you don't mind?
I guess it just means that you're, it means that on,
screens, it's hard to detect cancer.
Okay.
Because it's, I guess it's a little bit like a forest or something.
I don't know.
But there's like too many, it's too dense and busy.
比如，那是什么情况？如果可以的话，那是什么？我想这只是意味着你，这意味着在屏幕上，很难检测到癌症。好的。因为它是，我想它有点像森林什么的。我不知道。但有太多，它太致密且繁忙了。
Like vascular and cardiovascular kind of things.
Yeah.
But all jokes aside, that's scary.
That's scary.
Yeah.
So I was used to going, I go all the time.
I go every six months.
I get ultrasounds and as well as mammograms.
比如血管和心血管之类的东西。是的。但撇开玩笑不谈，那很可怕。那很可怕。是的。所以我习惯了去，我一直去。我每六个月去一次。我做超声波和乳房X光检查。
And so she found something on the Friday of Labor Day weekend.
And right before I left, she said, I said to her,
do you think if you were a betting woman, what would you say?
And she said, I think it's cancer.
Oh, my God.
So I went home.
You had to wait for the results for the test.
Yes.
所以她在劳动节周末的周五发现了一些东西。就在我离开之前，她说，我对她说，你觉得如果你是一个打赌的女人，你会怎么说？她说，我觉得是癌症。天哪。所以我回家了。你必须等待测试结果。是的。
So then she said she was going to walk it over to Cedars because it was a holiday weekend.
I was like, I talk about Xanax.
So I came home and then the next day,
David went down to San Diego
while we were waiting to hear from the doctor
because the kids had a soccer tournament
and my sister called and told me that my dad was about to die.
So I flew to New York and
所以她说她要把结果送到雪松西奈医院，因为那是假期周末。我就想，谈谈阿普唑仑。所以我回家了，第二天，大卫去了圣地亚哥，当我们等待医生的消息时，因为孩子们有足球锦标赛，我姐姐打电话告诉我我爸爸快要死了。所以我飞往纽约，
and my poor sister
had just dropped her last kid off at college
and...
So she's in a great mood.
So she was dealing with a lot of closure and loss
and so my dad passed away and...
I'm so sorry.
Thank you.
我可怜的姐姐刚把她最后一个孩子送到大学……所以她心情很好。所以她正在处理很多结束和失去，所以我爸爸去世了，而且……我很抱歉。谢谢。
Yeah.
The essay is really, really funny.
It actually is.
This is what, this is, this is her, her superpower.
It is, it has the most devastating things in it and the most hilarious stuff in the middle.
It's really something to work to read.
I can't wait to read it.
So anyway, when I got on the plane to come back to L.A.
是的。这篇文章真的，真的很有趣。它确实是。这就是，这是，这是她的，她的超能力。它里面有最令人心碎的事情，中间也有最搞笑的东西。读起来真的很值得。我迫不及待想读它。总之，当我坐飞机回洛杉矶时。
To get ready to get all the tests and go through the whole process of having breast cancer,
I was like, surely I can.
right about this. Surely this is a weekend from hell that there's got to, it's got to be.
But you're not thinking New Yorker. You're thinking just sort of a cathartic kind of let me just
journal. Yeah, I wasn't thinking that far ahead. I was just like, this can't be that common.
I mean, not that like I, you know, I mean. The weekend from hell. Yeah, the weekend from hell was
sort of what I was thinking. Yeah. And we, meanwhile, my mom was also in hospice. So both my parents
were in hospice at the exact same time.
准备好做所有的检查，经历患乳腺癌的整个过程，我就想，我肯定能写这个。这肯定是一个地狱般的周末，一定有，一定有。但你没想过《纽约客》。你只是想，这是一种宣泄，让我写日记。是的，我没想那么远。我只是想，这不可能那么普遍。我的意思是，不是说我，你知道，我的意思是。地狱般的周末。是的，地狱般的周末是我当时想的。是的。而且我们，与此同时，我妈妈也在临终关怀中。所以我的父母同时在临终关怀中。
Jesus Christ.
You know, I just...
It's all this past year.
Just now.
Six months.
Yeah, just now. Yeah, six months.
And I was very lucky.
Everything's, you know, I'm clear.
天哪。你知道，我只是……这是过去这一年。就在现在。六个月。是的，就在现在。是的，六个月。我很幸运。一切都，你知道，我清除了。
I did radiation.
I have extremely lucky the cancer they found.
It was cancer.
It was cancer, yeah, yeah.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't know.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah.
我做了放射治疗。我非常幸运，他们发现的癌症。那是癌症。那是癌症，是的，是的。我很抱歉。我不知道。哦，谢谢。是的。
So I was, like I said, like very, very lucky.
No one knew this, right?
I mean, it is in the article is your first mentioned,
the first time you've gone public with this?
Yes?
Yeah, I think because, you know, we didn't tell the kids right away because, you know, Frankie,
we dropped Frankie off at college the week before.
So we, and as some people know this, but cancer, most types of cancer, it takes a while
所以我，就像我说的，非常，非常幸运。没人知道这一点，对吧？我的意思是，文章里是你第一次提到，你第一次公开这件事？是的？是的，我想因为，你知道，我们没有马上告诉孩子们，因为，你知道，弗兰基，我们在前一周把弗兰基送到了大学。所以我们，正如有些人知道的那样，但是癌症，大多数类型的癌症，需要一段时间。
to find out where you are.
Like, what is your treatability?
What kind of breast cancer do you have?
How big is your tumor?
And that tells you how to treat it.
Yeah.
But, and, you know, I found out later, now I know so much more about breast cancer.
and other cancers too.
才能找出你的情况。比如，你的可治疗性是什么？你患的是哪种乳腺癌？你的肿瘤有多大？这决定了你怎么治疗它。是的。但是，而且，你知道，我后来才知道，现在我对乳腺癌了解多了很多。还有其他癌症。
I mean, there are types of pediatric leukemia
where you don't find out for a year
whether you have a treatable course.
But the waiting is insane making.
It's just insane making.
So, yeah, we didn't want to tell the kids for a while
until we knew whether I was going to do chemo
and what the course of treatment was going to be.
我的意思是，有些类型的儿童白血病，你一年都不知道你是否有可治疗的疗程。但等待是令人发疯的。这简直令人发疯。所以，是的，我们有一段时间不想告诉孩子们，直到我们知道我是否要化疗，以及治疗过程会是什么样。
So I wanted to keep it a secret
because I wasn't even telling my children.
Wow. Wow.
And then your dad passed while you were waiting for the...
While he was on the plane, yeah.
While you were in the plane there.
Yeah.
But you got there in time to say goodbye.
所以我不想保密，因为我甚至没告诉我的孩子们。哇。哇。然后你爸爸在你等待……的时候去世了。当他在飞机上时，是的。当你在飞机上时。是的。但你及时赶到了那里说再见。
Yes.
Yeah, it's all in the article.
Jason.
The essay, it's like it's so well written.
So wait.
So then now you're,
now you get home, you're starting your treatments, your, your mom, you're being a saint,
she's living with you in hospice. Yeah, Jason, Jason has come and seen my mom many times. So she,
是的。是的，都在文章里。杰森。这篇文章，它写得太好了。所以等等。所以现在你，现在你回家了，你开始治疗了，你的，你的妈妈，你是个圣人，她和你住在一起进行临终关怀。是的，杰森，杰森来看过我妈妈很多次。所以她，
yeah, she was single. My parents got divorced and she was single and living in New York. And so
she has Parkinson's disease. So once she was wheelchair-bound, we, David being, all jokes aside,
the mensch to end all menches, moved my mom here. And we took her.
So she was living here for the last seven years.
I mean, your stuff that you write about, your connections with her right there at the end,
or just everything.
That's so beautiful.
I had no idea all these years that your mom was living with you.
是的，她是单身。我父母离婚了，她单身住在纽约。所以她患有帕金森病。所以一旦她坐轮椅了，我们，大卫，撇开玩笑不谈，是所有好人中的好人，把我妈妈搬到了这里。我们带她来了。所以她过去七年一直住在这里。我的意思是，你写的东西，你和她在那最后的联系，或者只是所有的一切。太美了。我不知道这些年来你妈妈一直和你住在一起。
You never talked about it in any way.
And you're like managing this, you know, vibrant career that is after all these years,
even more vibrant and...
Writing and doing stuff and you're shooting that show.
in New York, right? You're shooting your show with Ham
in New York at the same time.
Shooting with Ham, yeah. They were really
lovely, like last summer, before
你从来没以任何方式谈论过它。而且你还在管理这个，你知道，充满活力的职业生涯，在这么多年后，甚至更有活力，而且……写作和做事情，你正在拍摄那个节目。在纽约，对吧？你同时在纽约和哈姆拍摄你的节目。和哈姆一起拍摄，是的。他们真的很可爱，就像去年夏天，在……
I found out, I had breast cancer
Tropper
and John Hamm were very beautiful about
my mom being in hospice
and letting me go back and forth all the
time. Like, I have very
special bosses, I have to say.
Well, this is really amazing
我发现之前，我患了乳腺癌，特罗珀和约翰·哈姆对我妈妈在临终关怀中非常体贴，让我一直来回奔波。我的意思是，我必须说，我有非常特别的老板。好吧，这真的很神奇。
because every time,
I didn't know any of this was going on.
So, every time
see you, I always laugh.
I was such a great time with you.
Same here. And you're always so
positive and have so much light
about you and around you. It's
因为每次，我不知道所有这些正在发生。所以，每次见到你，我总是笑。我和你在一起度过了很棒的时光。我也是。而且你总是那么积极，周围有那么多光芒。它是……
a Zanax, you guys.
It's not down or dripping. No, it's like
you're always laughing. Well, there's Ritalin.
She does a sidecar of Ritalin
as well.
Sidecar.
Sidecar, riddleon.
It's true, though.
阿普唑仑，伙计们。不是什么下垂。不，就像你总是笑。嗯，有利他林。她也有一份利他林的配菜。配菜。配菜，利他林。不过是真的。
I really want a sidecar of Ritalin.
She is the light.
She is sunshine.
You're such a, you're such a
joy.
Like, it's just amazing that
to know what just goes to show.
You have no idea what anybody's going through.
我真的很想要一份利他林的配菜。她是光。她是阳光。你真是，你真是个快乐。就像，知道这些真是太神奇了。这足以说明。你根本不知道别人正在经历什么。
Right.
Yeah.
I think my mom, thank you, first of all.
But, yeah, my mom is that way.
Like, a very Jewish sense of humor.
Like, very, we're asking about what I miss about New York.
Like, she has that very New York-y,
neurotic Jew, sharp, witty sense of humor.
对。是的。我想我妈妈，首先谢谢你。但是，是的，我妈妈就是那样。就像，非常有犹太幽默感。就像，非常，我们问关于我怀念纽约的什么。就像，她有那种非常纽约式的、神经质的犹太人、尖锐、机智的幽默感。
And throughout her Parkinson's, you know,
I mean it's an horrible disease
I know you guys probably know a little bit about it
and she never really lost her sense of humor
that's amazing never never so I have a good model for
as Carrie Fisher said always look for the humor
yeah yeah for sure
all right so we're going to take a look at that essay for sure
在她的帕金森病期间，你知道，我的意思是这是一种可怕的疾病，我知道你们可能对此了解一点，她从未真正失去她的幽默感，这太神奇了，从来没有，从来没有。所以我有一个很好的榜样，正如凯莉·费雪所说，永远寻找幽默。是的，是的，当然。好吧，所以我们肯定会看看那篇文章。
are we going to a clip or
For the,
Yeah, it did sound like you were about to go to a clip.
For the folks who don't know how to read
and just enjoy their dose of Amanda Pete
on the screen,
they've been enjoying your friends and neighbors
quite a lot.
我们要去看片段吗？或者，是的，听起来你确实要去看片段了。对于那些不知道怎么阅读，只想在屏幕上享受阿曼达·皮特剂量的人来说，他们一直很喜欢你的朋友和邻居。
Yeah.
As I would imagine.
As I did.
You are too, Amanda,
notwithstanding the hours spent with John Hamm.
Because that can be,
tough.
You know, this guy...
是的。正如我所料。正如我所做的那样。你也是，阿曼达，尽管花了时间和约翰·哈姆在一起。因为那可能，很艰难。你知道，这个家伙……
That would be trying.
He's a nightmare.
Let's face it.
Yeah.
Well, you know, maybe this is...
People will catch on.
People catch on and we'll finally be rid of them.
那会很折磨人。他是个噩梦。让我们面对现实吧。让我们面对现实吧。是的。嗯，你知道，也许这是……人们会明白的。人们会明白的，我们最终会摆脱他们。
But until then, you guys are great on this show.
The second season is coming up here in the spring, as well as your new film.
Let's talk about your new film.
It's called Fantasy Life.
released March 27th.
You are a producer.
You are a producer on that and also
the co-star
但在此之前，你们在这个节目上表现得很棒。第二季将在春天播出，还有你的新电影。让我们谈谈你的新电影。它叫《幻想生活》。3月27日上映。你是制片人。你是那部电影的制片人，也是联合主演。
and you were awarded, what were you awarded for that?
Hold on, I don't want you to have to say it's yourself here.
I believe it was some sort of special award
at South by Southwest.
The film won the audience award as well.
I mean, this is, and I saw it the other night
and it's effing great.
It's a real naturalistic, you know, let's put it this way.
你获得了，你因为那个获得了什么？等等，我不想让你在这里自己说出来。我相信那是西南偏南电影节的某种特别奖。这部电影也赢得了观众奖。我的意思是，这是，我前几天看了它，它太棒了。这是一种非常自然主义的，你知道，我们这样说吧。
If you loved Will Arnett's film, and I know all of our listeners did, you will love this film too.
It's got a lot of the same really great naturalistic sort of texture to it, if you will.
No one's swinging for the fences with some like, watch my performance crap.
It's really effortless quality.
When does it come out, Amanda?
I was swinging for the fences.
With a literal bat.
You never ask the audience to watch your performance.
如果你喜欢威尔·阿奈特的电影，我知道我们所有的听众都喜欢，你也会喜欢这部电影。它有很多同样非常棒的自然主义质感，如果你愿意的话。没有人试图用那种“看我的表演”的垃圾来博眼球。这是一种非常轻松的品质。它什么时候上映，阿曼达？我当时在全力以赴。用一根真正的球棒。你从不要求观众看你的表演。
You're never screaming.
Like, hey, look at me, act.
It's so easy to watch you.
I'm screaming deep inside.
Look at me.
Whatever it is, it's working.
Was that a great sense of accomplishment?
Because you've been doing great work on,
你从不尖叫。就像，嘿，看着我，表演。看你演戏太容易了。我在内心深处尖叫。看着我。无论它是什么，它都在起作用。那是一种巨大的成就感吗？因为你一直在做伟大的工作，
this is what, your first film in 10 years.
Was that important for you?
Is that true?
People keep saying.
saying that, can I just say something?
It's not like I chose to not work in a movie for 10 years.
I just couldn't get arrested.
Yeah, but you're no longer, you know, pushing your headshots under doors and stuff.
这是什么，你10年来第一部电影。这对你很重要吗？那是真的吗？人们一直说。说那个，我能说点什么吗？并不是我选择10年不拍电影。我只是没法被逮捕。是的，但你不再是，你知道，把你的头像照塞进门下之类的了。
I mean, as you said, you've got this healthy, sexy, indifference guys.
Yeah.
And you're busy doing things that are a little bit more important to you, I would imagine.
Yes?
Honestly, it's really just what is the writing good?
And in this particular case, this indie writer came to me with this idea of, this was before baby girl, it's basically like a sort of upper crust mom who has...
This is Matthew Shear?
The upper crust mom, yeah.
我的意思是，正如你所说，你有这种健康、性感、冷漠的家伙。是的。而且你忙于做一些对你来说更重要的事情，我想象。是吗？老实说，这真的只是写作好吗？在这个特定的案例中，这个独立作家带着这个想法来找我，这是在《宝贝女孩》之前，它基本上就像一个上流社会的妈妈，她有……这是马修·希尔？上流社会的妈妈，是的。
Yes, but Matthew Shear, it's like she has an affair with the manny, basically.
She has a character you play.
Yes.
And when I read the script on about page 15,
this neurotic, speaking of neurotic Jews from New York,
he has a scene with his shrink where he's talking about his OCD with Judd Hirsch,
and he's having these self-hating Jew intrusive thoughts
where he sees like a Jewish guy on the subway with a big nose like David,
是的，但马修·希尔，就像她和保姆有染，基本上。她有一个你扮演的角色。是的。当我读到剧本第15页左右时，这个神经质的，说到纽约的神经质犹太人，他和他的心理医生有一场戏，他在和贾德·赫希谈论他的强迫症，他有这些自我厌恶的犹太人侵入性想法，他看到地铁上有一个像大卫那样大鼻子的犹太人，
and he says, hook knows, hook knows, hook knows.
And he thinks he's going to say it out.
loud and I was like well this is brilliant I want to do this.
Oh wow.
It's just so fucking funny.
It's really a lot funnier than how I'm pitching it right now.
No, it is it's but again it's not asking for laughs.
It's really tasteful.
他说，钩鼻子，钩鼻子，钩鼻子。他以为他会大声说出来，我就想，嗯，这太天才了，我想做这个。哦，哇。它太他妈有趣了。它真的比我现在推销它的方式有趣得多。不，它是，它是，但同样，它不是在乞求笑声。它真的很有品味。
Alessandro Naval is in it with you as well.
How funny is he?
Yeah, he's great.
Wait, when does it come out?
March 27th.
Which I believe has already passed.
We're doing this a little bit ahead of time.
亚历山德罗·纳瓦尔也和你在一起。他有多有趣？是的，他很棒。等等，它什么时候上映？3月27日。3月27日。我相信那已经过去了。我们做这个有点提前了。
But yeah, we are...
No, I know that, obviously.
It's in theaters now.
Go out there and grab it, y'all.
Now, what is my next question?
Here I come.
I'm coming down to the page here.
I know.
但是是的，我们是……不，我知道那个，显然。它现在在影院上映。去那里抓住它，你们所有人。现在，我的下一个问题是什么？我来了。我正沿着页面下来。我知道。
Jamie, just go off script a little bit.
Just, you know, what do you do for fun?
Well, you know what she does for fun.
Yeah.
Dents and busy.
Oh, no, that's what Will does for fun.
Wait, Amanda, what does the rest of the day look like today?
杰米，稍微脱离剧本一点。只是，你知道，你平时做什么娱乐？嗯，你知道她做什么娱乐。是的。致密且繁忙。致密且繁忙。哦，不，那是威尔做什么娱乐。等等，阿曼达，今天剩下的时间看起来怎么样？
No, that's a great question.
question. Yeah, let's do that one.
This is the most hard-hitting journalism.
No, you're not.
Are you out of your mind?
I'm really boring.
No, I want to know. I want to know because I want to, first of all, I didn't know anything
that you've gone through in this past six months or year.
不，那是个好问题。问题。是的，让我们做那个。这是最硬核的新闻。不，你不是。你疯了吗？我很无聊。不，我想知道。我想知道，因为我想，首先，我不知道你在过去六个月或一年里经历的一切。
And now I want to know, like, what do you do all day?
Because the kids are away, right?
What do you do all day?
Like, because, you're about to start, are you about to start press for, for both the
film and the show?
Yes.
And is that something that you like?
Do you like going out there and doing all the chat and giggles?
现在我想知道，比如，你整天做什么？因为孩子们不在，对吧？你整天做什么？比如，因为，你快要开始，你快要开始为电影和节目做宣传了吗？是的。那是你喜欢的事情吗？你喜欢出去做所有的聊天和笑话吗？
What do you guys think?
I feel like when you're proud of it.
It all depends on sleep.
If I slept, I'm great.
I'm going to do anything.
I'm tired.
I don't want to do it.
Do you have trouble sleeping?
你们怎么看？我觉得当你为它感到骄傲时。这完全取决于睡眠。如果我睡了，我很好。我会做任何事。我很累。我不想做。你有睡眠困难吗？
Let's talk about sleep because...
Yeah.
I think as you get older and smarter and the brain works better,
and there's more stuff to think about,
sleeping gets harder.
Yes.
And I just read somewhere that it used to be...
By red, you mean TikTok.
让我们谈谈睡眠，因为……是的。我觉得随着你变老变聪明，大脑工作得更好，有更多的事情要思考，睡眠变得更难。是的。我刚在某处读到，它曾经是……你说的读是指TikTok。
Uh-huh.
It's on TikTok.
By the way, it's true.
I think I did see it on TikTok.
Where the, where you sleep.
It used to be hundreds of years ago,
people only slept for three or four hours, got up,
and then there was a second sleep.
嗯哼。它在TikTok上。顺便说一句，这是真的。我想我确实在TikTok上看到了它。你睡觉的地方。几百年前，人们只睡三四个小时，起床，然后有第二次睡眠。
Yeah.
Says who.
TikTok.
That is true.
Yeah.
He's right.
And then so that's kind of what happens to me.
I sleep for a little bit.
是的。谁说的。TikTok。那是真的。是的。他是对的。所以这就是发生在我身上的事情。我睡一会儿。
There was a time in New York you can look it up
where people used to go and they'd walk around
in the middle of the night.
It would be, I remember reading this, there was a book about it, about these,
and people would walk around sort of at like 1 a.m.
And there'd be like a kind of a nightlife that people,
sort of before the advent of widespread.
They've got to get your eight hours.
在纽约有一段时间，你可以查一下，人们过去常常去，他们在半夜四处走动。我会，我记得读过这个，有一本书是关于这个的，关于这些，人们会在凌晨1点左右四处走动。会有某种夜生活，人们，在广泛普及之前。他们必须睡够八小时。
Electric bulbs and all that kind of.
And that people would go to sleep earlier.
And then often wake up in the night and they would have like a reprieve from their sleeping.
I am definitely looking that up.
Go for you.
Are you guys, are you ruminators when you wake up?
How do you keep your brain from being like, death?
We're all going to die.
电灯泡和所有那种。而且人们会更早睡觉。然后经常在夜里醒来，他们会从睡眠中得到喘息。我肯定会查一下那个。为你加油。你们是反刍者吗，当你们醒来时？你们怎么让大脑不像是，死亡？我们都要死了。
Catastrophic thinking.
Do you have catastrophic thinking?
Yeah.
You do?
I mean, I've been, yeah.
But so how do you stop yourself, Sean, when you,
so you have two sections of sleep with a thing in the middle?
So what, are you able to put your phone away?
灾难化思维。你有灾难化思维吗？有。真的吗？我是说，我一直，是的。但是肖恩，当你，当你把睡眠分成两段，中间还有别的事要做时，你是怎么让自己停下来的？你是能把手机放下吗？
No, no, I play games or I'll read or do whatever on my computer.
You know, like I'll look, read, I'll read stuff that I find interesting.
But most of the time I'll play games.
But doesn't the blue light?
Didn't people tell you not to put the blue?
I have glasses that's soft in the blue light.
So that's a great look.
You've got the glasses on, the CPAP, and the,
不，不，我会玩游戏，或者看书，或者在电脑上做点别的。你知道，我会看，读，读一些我觉得有趣的东西。但大多数时候我会玩游戏。但是蓝光呢？难道没人告诉你不要看蓝光吗？我有防蓝光眼镜。那看起来很棒。你戴着眼镜，用着呼吸机，还有，
and then you got the, what's it called, the Beetlejuice?
What's the, what's the game you play?
Candy cry.
Candy crush.
That's hot.
But it's more about what that's doing,
sort of firing all those things in your brain instead of,
然后你还有那个，叫什么来着，甲壳虫汁？你玩的是什么游戏？糖果传奇。糖果粉碎传奇。那很火。那很火。但这更多是关于它在做什么，它在刺激你大脑里的所有东西，而不是，
In that moment, if you were to wake up and pick up a book,
you might find it easier to get into sleep.
Will is constantly pushing reading on this podcast.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
Mostly about World War II, though.
Not recently.
No?
World War I now?
在那一刻，如果你醒来拿起一本书，你可能会发现更容易入睡。威尔在这个播客里一直在推崇阅读。抱歉。抱歉。不过主要是关于二战的。最近不是了。不是吗？现在是第一次世界大战？
Or are we into Vietnam?
Which direction are you going?
The last, you know what?
The last couple weeks, I've been into more sort of modern noir.
Okay.
And I did one of those things, right?
I said, what are the best modern noir books of the last 10 years?
What would you say?
还是我们进入越南战争了？你往哪个方向走？你知道吗？过去几周，我更多地接触了现代黑色小说。好的。我做了其中一件事，对吧？我说，过去10年最好的现代黑色小说是什么？你会怎么说？
What do you say?
Yeah.
And they sent me a list of books and I...
You know Noir?
And I just read about it.
Uh-huh.
Oh, sorry, Sean.
Hang on.
你怎么说？是的。他们给我发了一份书单，我……你知道黑色小说吗？我刚读了关于它的内容。嗯哼。哦，抱歉，肖恩。等等。
Sorry, Sean.
A little late.
Little late on the draw there.
Wait, is that fiction or nonfiction?
Fission.
It's been like sort of like crime and, yeah, yeah, yeah, it's been interesting.
I know it's so good that you read all that well.
That's so good.
抱歉，肖恩。晚了一点。反应有点慢。等等，那是小说还是非虚构作品？虚构作品。它就像是犯罪之类的，是的，是的，是的，很有趣。我知道你能读完所有这些真是太好了。那太好了。
Do you read a lot, Amanda?
I try.
Yeah, I try to read a lot.
I, um...
David reads a lot.
David and I've exchanged books.
I know.
We've handed each other books before.
阿曼达，你读得多吗？我尽量。是的，我尽量多读点。我，嗯……大卫读得很多。大卫和我交换过书。我知道。我们以前互相递过书。
And now he's listening to The Rest is History.
Do you know that podcast?
Yes.
He's obsessed.
Yeah, it's very good.
It's really fun.
What is it?
Like an audio book or something?
现在他在听《历史的余味》（The Rest is History）。你知道那个播客吗？知道。他着迷了。是的，非常好。真的很有趣。那是什么？有声读物之类的吗？
It's a podcast.
And they talk about history, but in a very accessible,
hilarious.
For dumb dumps like me?
For dumbdums like me.
Yeah, like I'm doing the one on Iran right now.
Oh, wow.
And they're so, they're, Will, don't you think they're so funny?
那是一个播客。他们谈论历史，但以一种非常平易近人、搞笑的方式。像我这样的笨蛋也能听吗？像我这样的笨蛋。是的，比如我现在正在听关于伊朗的那一期。哦，哇。他们太，他们，威尔，你不觉得他们很搞笑吗？
Very, very interesting.
Not as funny as you guys, but they're funny.
But where do people have the time to listen to podcasts?
On the finger dinger.
Where are you getting in the car?
No, I'm watching news when I'm on the thing.
But J.B., if you look about it, look at it this way.
You dedicate, I'd say 80% of your time that you watch TV, which is about 80% of your day, is you're watching news.
非常，非常有意思。虽然没有你们那么搞笑，但他们很有趣。但是人们哪有时间听播客呢？在手指上。你在车里听吗？不，我在看新闻的时候就在看那个。但是J.B.，如果你换个角度看，如果你换个角度看。你投入了，我想说你80%看电视的时间，也就是你一天中80%的时间，都在看新闻。
The other 20 you're watching sports.
I keep waiting for him to get caught, you know.
No, no, no.
My point is, if you were to delegate some of that,
time to listen to sitting in a chair in a room with headphones on staring at the wall while you're on the
exercise machine or i do it in the car will in the car yeah in the car and listen to these guys i think
you'd find it pretty interesting but i can't finish it my car rides are like 15 20 minutes is that
okay and you just pop in pop in pop out yeah you'd pick i do that with them especially if you're
剩下的20%你在看体育节目。我一直在等他被抓到，你知道的。不，不，不。我的意思是，如果你能分出一些时间来听，坐在房间的椅子上戴着耳机盯着墙，或者当你在健身器材上时，或者我在车里做，威尔，在车里，是的，在车里听这些家伙，我想你会发现它很有趣。但我听不完，我的车程只有15到20分钟，那没关系吗？你只要随听随停就行了。是的，你会选，我就是这样听他们的，特别是如果你对
interested in one section will it hold my place i don't want to have to start over when i get back
I just take a screenshot of where I am,
and that's how I know how many minutes have gone by,
and then I return to it.
Of course you do.
You can probably do it in an easier way.
I love that you do that.
Boy, that says everything.
某一部分感兴趣的话，威尔，它会保存我的进度吗？我不想回来的时候从头开始。我只是截个图记录我在哪里，这就是我知道过了多少分钟的方法，然后我再回到那里。你当然会这么做。你可能有更简单的方法。我喜欢你这样做。天哪，这说明了一切。
Really?
Yeah, that taught me a lot in a great way.
I'm scared.
No, no, no, no.
It's very methodical, and I really appreciate that.
Well, she's a Capricorn.
I'm a Capricorn.
You know, we think shit through.
真的吗？是的，这在很大程度上教会了我很多。我很害怕。不，不，不，不。这非常有条理，我真的很欣赏这一点。好吧，她是摩羯座。我也是摩羯座。你知道，我们做事深思熟虑。
Fuck that.
I need to give a shout out to Amanda Anka and say that I'm a Capricorn, yeah.
Yeah.
What are you guys, Sean?
She knows you're rising and you're whatever.
No, she still needs more information, apparently, to tell me exactly what I am.
I am cancer.
How about that?
去他的。我得向阿曼达·安卡致敬，说我是摩羯座的，是的。是的。你们是什么星座，肖恩？她知道你的上升星座和你是什么星座。不，显然她还需要更多信息才能准确告诉我我是什么。我是巨蟹座。那又怎样？
Oh, wow.
In every situation.
Yeah.
I'm like a modern-day Fred Nord.
I'm like a low-rate Fred Nordstrom-Hauer, yeah.
Wait, Sean, what's your rising?
I don't know what that means.
哦，哇。在任何情况下。是的。在任何情况下。我就像现代版的弗雷德·诺德。我就像个低配版的弗雷德·诺德斯特伦-豪尔，是的。等等，肖恩，你的上升星座是什么？我不知道那是什么意思。
Okay, me neither.
Will, what about you?
Sean, you don't have a joke for what's rising?
and Sean?
Taurus.
Bois,
好吧，我也不知道。威尔，你呢？肖恩，你对上升星座没有笑话吗？还有肖恩？金牛座。金牛座。伙计们，伙计们，
Will,
you know what your rising is?
I forget,
but Amanda,
Amanda Ake does that.
She's got it all on us.
She's got a full forecast for all of us.
伙计们，威尔，你知道你的上升星座是什么吗？我忘了，但阿曼达，阿曼达·安卡知道。她掌握了我们所有人的信息。她为我们所有人做了完整的预测。
So she could, yeah.
She could tell us what's what
in the coming.
You're right.
I had to send Amanda,
Anka
like a year ago or whatever,
like what time.
所以她可以，是的。她可以告诉我们未来会发生什么。你说得对。我大概一年前不得不发给阿曼达·安卡，或者类似的时间。
I had to ask my mom
exactly what time
day I was born.
I did all this stuff.
She needed to have all this information.
She wanted to know
if you were a good match for her or not.
She already knew.
我不得不问我妈妈我到底是几点出生的。我做了所有这些事。她需要掌握所有这些信息。她想知道你是不是她的良配。她早就知道了。
Yet she's sticking with me.
I love her so much.
She better.
And you don't want to know who else I love so much?
Who?
The other Amanda in my life.
Amanda Pete, today's guest.
她早就知道了。但她还是和我在一起。我太爱她了。她最好是这样。而且你不想知道我还深爱着谁吗？谁？我生命中的另一个阿曼达。今天的嘉宾，阿曼达·皮特。
And we want to thank you for your hour and eight minutes.
We love you.
We certainly do.
I love you.
I love all three of you so much.
We love you so much, too.
We love your husband, your three kids, the whole thing.
I love you.
我们要感谢你这一小时零八分钟的时间。我们爱你。我们当然爱你。我爱你。我非常爱你们三个。我们也爱你。我们爱你丈夫，你的三个孩子，所有的一切。我爱你。
And your talent.
So go out there, read that essay in The New Yorker, watch your movie fantasy life,
watch your show, your friends and neighbors, and stay tuned for the next half of this incredible
woman's career and life.
Oh, my God, I'm going to start crying.
I'm going to cry.
I know how you.
That was so nice.
还有你的才华。所以去吧，读那篇《纽约客》的文章，看你的电影《幻想生活》，看你的剧《朋友与邻居》，并继续关注这位了不起的女性职业生涯和生活的下一半。哦，天哪，我要哭了。我要哭了。我知道你的感受。那太好了。
We love you.
We do love you.
I do love you the best.
Thank you so much.
I love you, gentlemen, so much.
I'm going to hug you so hard when I see you.
Is that a bit of a sense?
I promise us.
我们爱你。我们确实爱你。我最爱你。非常感谢。我非常爱你们，先生们。见到你们时我会给你们一个大大的拥抱。那算是一种感觉吗？我向我们保证。
Squeeze me.
Okay.
Love you.
All right.
Bye.
Love you guys.
抱抱我。好的。爱你。好的。再见。爱你们。再见。再见。
Bye.
I love you too.
That was Amanda Pete.
One of my dearest, longest friends.
I know.
One of my all-time faves.
再见。我也爱你。再见。再见。那是阿曼达·皮特。我最亲爱、相识最久的朋友之一。我知道。我一直以来最喜欢的人之一。
Same.
Super funny.
Yeah.
And like I said, she's always so bright.
No one would ever know anything's going on ever.
No.
She's always.
Not that that like, you know, it's just somebody who knows how to.
我也是。超级搞笑。是的，就像我说的，她总是那么开朗。没人会知道发生了什么。不。她总是。并不是说，你知道，这只是有人知道如何。
I know.
Always walk in a room and light it up.
Yeah, for sure.
screen too like i just she's just always sort of ground stuff that i watch um and uh always kind of
elevates it kind of smarts it up you know what j b i have a recollection of before you guys were friends
before you'd work together that you always admire you used to talk about her in this way that she was for you
like kind of the gold standard and she was like one of those people you wanted to work with her really
yeah yeah you know you know in the best way yeah yeah yeah and tayleone was like that for me too yeah
我知道。总是走进房间并点亮它。是的，当然。屏幕上也是，我只是，她总是能让我在看的东西变得扎实，嗯，而且总是能提升它，让它变得更聪明，你知道吗，J.B.，我记得在你们成为朋友之前，在你们合作之前，你总是很钦佩她，你过去常以这种方式谈论她，她对你来说就像是黄金标准，她是那种你想和她合作的人，真的吗？是的，是的，你知道，以最好的方式，是的，是的，泰·里奥妮对我来说也是这样，是的
and still to this day like i just think there's there's a julia
Roberts is like that too.
There's a strength and a style of humor and also of drama that, I don't know,
that all kind of remind me of each other.
But yeah.
She is a treasure.
And, Sean, right about now is when you start to say, hey, guys, have you ever...
I'm looking.
直到今天，我仍然认为，朱莉娅·罗伯茨也是这样。有一种力量、一种幽默风格，还有戏剧性，我不知道，它们都让我想起了彼此。但是是的。她是个宝藏。而且，肖恩，现在正是你开始说，嘿，伙计们，你们有没有……我在看。
Do you remember the time that I...
Do you remember?
Hey, guys, you want to know what my favorite film of hers was?
And then he kind of works it in that way.
I'm coming.
Oh, God, wait.
We're going to cut out this pause and wait.
Oh, are we?
你记得那次我……你记得吗？嘿，伙计们，你们想知道我最喜欢她哪部电影吗？然后他会以那种方式引出话题。我来了。哦，天哪，等等。我们要剪掉这段停顿，等等。哦，我们要剪掉吗？
Yeah.
You know, that David Benioff, husband or hers, you know,
they've got kind of like a dual,
it's a double-barrel shotgun over there of talent
and accomplishments.
And they're sort of...
You know.
Yeah.
是的。你知道，大卫·贝尼奥夫，她的丈夫，你知道，他们在那边就像是一个双管猎枪，拥有才华和成就。他们有点……你知道。是的。
Sorry.
And...
You know.
You know, yeah.
I thought that would be a great tea up there for one of you guys.
I know.
Wait, yes.
Oh, God, we've got a caller.
抱歉。而且……你知道。你知道，是的。我以为那会是你们其中一个人的绝佳引子。我知道。等等，是的。哦，天哪，我们有电话打进来了。
A caller is, uh, oh, you know, one of my favorite jobs that I've ever done.
And Amanda P happened to be in it.
We talked about it earlier.
Um, a real treat.
Yeah.
My friend, my favorite, Amanda P.
played my wife in, by identity thief.
That was pretty good.
一个来电者是，嗯，哦，你知道，我做过的最喜欢的工作之一。阿曼达·皮特恰好也在里面。我们之前谈过。嗯，真是个享受。是的。我的朋友，我最喜欢的阿曼达·皮特在《身份窃贼》里扮演我的妻子。那部电影很不错。
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjav and Bennett Barbico.
Smartless.
Smartless由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗伯·阿姆贾夫和贝内特·巴比科100%有机且手工制作。Smartless。